What is up everybody? Thanks for joining
us at Candid Truth. We're going to talk
about the truth and we're going to get
candid with it. Tonight is part number
three, the long awaited third part
because my brother Ernest has been
bringing the studies about who is the
king of the north and king of the south
and we've been looking at this stuff.
Brother, thank you so much for coming
back on again. This has been one of the
deepest studies I think we've ever done
about something like this and I'm
learning a lot. I'm seeing a lot of
comments from people that are saying
they're blessed. They're learning a lot.
So, I just really wanted to say thank
you for coming on again and I can't wait
to hear what you're going to present
tonight.
Well, it was a blessing to have me on
once again. I know it's been long
overdue. Um um I know I was mentioning
to some other people the other day that
um
you and I had set it up actually last
week. We were supposed to go live last
Sunday, right? Was it last Sunday? I
can't take a wife. I think so.
>> And it was something like that, right?
But it just one thing led to another
because I was traveling. I was speaking
at a different location and just things
started to get involved. I mean, I just
couldn't sit down to really concentrate
to get everything all prepared. Then on
your end, something happened. You were
traveling, too.
>> So, it was a back and forth. So, we
couldn't but when we talked earlier
today, remember that um I we believe
that when we look back in retrospect,
it's like, you know, we believe it's the
Lord's timing. And you will see with the
today's meeting the reason why. So, I I
think the Lord had to hold have us hold
out until now.
>> I mean, sometimes I wish I could have a
little bit more time to fix up a little
bit more sides. But hey, we got to we
got to move forward, brother. People are
waiting. People have been asking me,
Ernest, when is the next one? When is
the next one? Like you said, people have
been asking you. So, here we are by the
grace of our Lord and Savior Jesus
Christ.
>> Amen. Somebody um somebody in here
mentioned uh let's see, have you reached
out to Tim Rosenberg on this topic?
these presentations align to what he has
been sharing for years in Advent Media
Connect. So, you're not the only one out
here seeing this, brother. That's pretty
cool.
>> Yeah, I know. There's a lot there's
other people of of course of my faith
that that hold to this view. Um those
that don't know um you know Tim
Rosenberg is one of those um I think
he's one of the major proponents that um
um believe on this um that believes this
topic to be as Islam to be being the
king of the south and of course people
like Christianity to the north. You have
also um John Peters, Dr. John Peters I
believe he did a phenomenal job years
ago. You can look up his information
online. Um and then of course Doug
Bachelor. Doug Bachelor. Matter of fact,
somebody just this was years ago that
they've, you know, they've went
airborne. They went, you know, they
they're not ashamed to share what they
believe.
>> Um, and then of course there's several
others if you will look when I'm talking
about people from within my church.
These are leaders that do are studying
this out and are going to or that are uh
actually going forward to present to the
people this particular view. Now Mikey,
let me just make sure that I
um state this once again. you know, you
can vouch for it as well. In my pre in
the previous meetings that we had, I
made it very clear that um our church
doesn't have an official um position on
this,
>> right?
>> And then of course um [clears throat]
people are still free to believe what
they want to believe. No one's obligated
to believe what I present. I'm as I
mentioned before and I I'll restate
again. I'm just bringing to the people
what I believe God has brought to my
attention and I'm presenting
what I believe is to be truth. Now
granted, I I have become biased upon
this subject because of what I've been
presenting, but I'm still open to hear
what anybody else says. And you know,
I've said it many times before and I'll
say it again. If you need to discuss it
with me, Mikey has put my number in the
description box. You can go ahead and
contact me. But folks, please, I'm not
in it for a debate, for an argument.
This is not the purpose of a study.
>> If you're one of those that tend to want
to debate and argue because you have
your mind around on a different point
of, you know, a dogma behind it, then
I'm not the one for you to call. Okay?
I'm sorry that I may have rattled your
cage a bit. If that's the case, I'm
sorry. That's not my intention. My
intention is just to present I have felt
that is true and it's up to you and or
is incumbent upon every hearer or those
that are watching to go study it out for
themselves. I believe I did my homework
and like I said before, if if if this is
wrong, it'll fall flat. If it's true,
we're going to see real soon.
>> But I'm not ashamed of it. I'm not here
to to push this cool agenda out to
people where I'm going to make it seem
like if you don't believe it this way,
your salvation is on at stake. And and
Mikey, unfortunately, there are people
that present topics and they make you
feel that if you don't accept it a
certain way, you're teaching heresy and
therefore your lost. Now, there are
teachings that are out there that's
clear that it's heresy. I mean,
>> it's I mean, it's clear,
>> but this is not one of those, you know,
and again, our church has gone on to to
um formally state or make official um
statement to the belief of who's who or
the identity of who's the north, the
south in Daniel 11. So therefore, it's
open open for discussion. It's open for
scrutiny scrutiny and it's open for for
I guess for conversations.
>> Yeah. I don't want to say.
>> Yeah. Not debate. [clears throat]
All right. Well, I'm going to throw your
u your slides up here so we can see
that. And I I love that you said what
you said because, you know, this is
candid truth.
>> It doesn't mean that we're always going
to have 100% perfect truth. I'm not
perfect. I'm not flawless, but it's
candid. We're getting candid. We're
studying with it. Candid means raw, you
know, uh unscripted. And I just made a
video yesterday, I think it was, and
something I said on there, you know, it
might not be completely accurate, but
I'm wanting people to I'm trying to
encourage people to uh think outside the
box, question things, study things out.
And there were other things presented in
that video that are true. Um, but I I I
put a little uh pinned comment in there
saying, you know, here's the original
video. I'm not seeing this little glitch
like uh I showed in this. So, it could
be, you know, somebody making a fake
fake post or whatever. Um the the object
of this channel is to present things
that most mainstream people are not
presenting on and to think outside the
box and to seek truth, try to find
truth. And don't just take our word for
it because we present it. Go fact check
us and let us know because we want to
know the truth, too.
>> [laughter]
>> Amen. I like how you said it really
quick.
>> Yeah.
>> So, no, I I I agree with you. Oh, and by
the way, I please people, if you if
there's anybody that tends to watch this
um presentation or any of the previous
ones, don't hack Mikey. He's not the one
that's presenting. He's just he's just
open to hearing it and he's not going to
be able to answer all the questions.
>> [snorts]
>> I mean, I'm probably the one that you
will probably have to talk to. So, don't
rail on him for him inviting me. I mean,
he you don't demonize the brother for
doing it. I mean, what kind of
Christians are we? We are we need to be
open to dialogue, you know, um to share
our differences. Um the apostles did not
agree in everything. So, I mean, it it's
just a fact. But if you want to speak to
somebody, contact me by trying to to to
state something different or opposing
view to Mikey is not going to do
anything if you're the one that thinks
that I'm the one that's not teaching
anything correct. That's, you know, and
again, I'm not going to take offense to
it. Unfortunately, there are people that
do.
You know, that's just a fact. They just
>> There's not many people that'll just put
their contact out there and say, "Hit me
up. Let's talk about it.
You know what I'm saying? They can they
can contact me. You know what I'm
saying? But again, we're going to we're
going to be speaking as reasonable
adults. We're I mean, we're not going to
again, we're not here. Jesus didn't
debate. Mikey, I've said that to you
many times. Jesus didn't debate. And I'm
not about to go doing this. If if if you
feel contrary to what you hear here,
you're free to believe what you want to
believe. You're free to believe. Pray
for me and I will continue to pray for
you. And by the way, in addition to
that, I will love you as well.
>> Amen. You know,
>> I got friends. I invite people on here
that I know for a fact believe different
than me, but we have similar beliefs on
other things and we'll talk about that
like-minded belief. And if something
gets brought up that I don't believe in,
right here on live air, I'll say, "I
don't believe in that, but you know,
let's continue." And we're going to be
friends.
>> We need to we need to grow together and
seek the truth together and all that.
>> That's right. And the Bible says to the
law to the testimony, "If they speak not
according to his word, there is no light
in them." I mean, that's just the way it
is. But again, there's people in in from
from my, you know, these are these are
my loving brothers from my church and
sisters from my church that don't hold
to this view, but there's no official
position, but they're making it seem
like sometimes they make it seem like
I'm either myself or Tim or Doug or
anybody else for John Peters or anybody
else for that matter that teaches
something opposite that they are
teaching heresy,
>> right?
>> Literally, you know what I'm saying?
They try to, you know, blacklist us, you
know. I won't do that to them. You know
what I'm saying? They're free to come
and dialogue with me. We'll be able to
talk. But I So, but nonetheless, Mikey,
I appreciate for you allowing me to come
back and to talk on this. And remember,
we're going to be talking on that 70
weeks. That's the one that I really want
to target.
>> That 70 weeks, the 490 years back in
Daniel chapter 9 about the seven-year
tribulation, the rapture theory
>> about it. We need to prepare people to
be able to give candid um um studies to
with people so they can see it for
themselves. Amen. Remember my of these
studies is to help teach people to teach
other people.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Making disciples.
>> You know
>> that Yeah. That's it. That's just what
I'm trying to do. But again, I'm going
to give you what I believe is facts. And
if it's wrong, then that's fine.
>> Right.
Well, there was our 10-minute
disclaimer. So, [laughter]
>> All right. So, I don't know. You want
you want us to go? I mean, let's you
want to you want to begin?
>> Yeah, let's do it.
>> Okay. Let um let's let's have a let's
have a word of prayer so that you know
the people that are viewing can see that
we are wanting to invite the presence of
our Lord.
>> Um Mike, once again, please, if you'll
be kind enough.
>> Yes. Lord, Father in heaven, we just
thank you so much for the opportunity to
get to do this, to have this technology
where we can stream your word live to
potentially thousands of people. And we
just pray for everyone that's in this
chat, that you would be uh among them,
that you would fill us all with your
spirit, that we would have good
conversation, that there would not be uh
battles going on in the chat room, that
people would actually uh hear what's
being presented. And Lord, if it's true,
then we ask that you would open our eyes
to it. Help us to receive this with open
hearts and open minds. And Lord, we just
want truth. So open our eyes. Give us
spiritual eyes because spiritual things
are spiritually discerned. Give us
discernment. And Lord, I just pray that
you'd be with me in earnest. Be with our
our mouths, our conversation, be with
our minds. Bring things to our memory
that we didn't even uh know would come
up that will help this study. and we
just ask that you would just be with the
technology and um just help everything
to go smoothly. We love you, Lord. Most
of all, we can't wait for you to return
and we live in exciting times and we
just want to be in your word, Lord. We
want to be um amongst your among your
people and fellowship, studying your
word and just being ready for your soon
return in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen. All right. All right. Thank you,
brother Mikey. So, a couple things just
let me just throw out the disclaimer.
Fair use notice copyright disclaimers se
under section 107 of the copyright act
of 1976 allowances made for the fair use
for such purposes such as criticism
comments news reporting teaching
scholarship education and research
remember that's what we are doing here
today
couple of things that I just want to
throw out um on the second part part two
of our program I entitled that
um presentation mentioned Daniel Leven's
North and South Kings extra. And what I
did was in the beginning of part two, I
recapped on what we talked about in part
one. Um, and what I did was when we got
landed to verse 40,
I then deviated and went to Revelation
11 and I dealt with the atheism aspect
and about France. The reason why I did
that was to reveal the reasons why I do
not believe that the king of the south
is atheism. Now, let me pause here for a
second. I did get some calls of people
that I do know or people that were on
this platform that did contact me, which
I did appreciate, and they had questions
about that. And the question that I
asked, I said, "Well, my question to you
is this. Did you watch the video in its
entirety?"
And they said, "No." I said, 'Well, this
this question would have been answered
if you watched it in its entirety.
>> If you watch, I believe at the time
stamp mark of 1 hour and 54 minutes.
From that point on, I'm more addressing
the people from my side of the coin,
that is from my church,
those that tend to believe differently
from me, those that t believe that the
king of the north, the identity of the
king of the north is atheism, I address
that. Mikey, you were there. You saw the
proof that I that I submitted.
>> Yep.
>> And after that, I didn't get the phone
calls any longer because I believe they
got to see it.
>> And that's what I'm encouraging your
viewers to go do
>> because some of us just basically cut it
off. Probably said too long or whatever.
Folks, this is this is a big study. I'm
not intending just to zip through it and
to eliminate information and then you
come back. People say, "Well, he didn't
submit no information." That's the
purpose of this. This is why this is
lengthy. I don't want to for it to be
lengthy, but I must to give you, I
believe, my proof to the why I believe
that the king in the south is atheism.
We'll get to that in a little bit, but
we're going to deal today with more of
the final crisis. As you can see,
>> I just want to clarify. It's not like
you said you were going to prove that
the king of the south is atheism. I
don't know if you slipped up or if I
misunderstood.
>> Okay, repeat that one more time. Sorry,
I probably did. I probably did.
>> Okay. Yeah, it just sound like you were
the last thing you said was uh your
proof that the king of the south is
atheism.
>> Okay. So, what I was basically trying to
say is is that I was trying to No, it
wasn't atheism. That's it. That it
wasn't atheism. Be
>> very clear. Thank you. Thank you for
that clarification.
>> Oh, you're welcome.
>> And then the and then the other thing
too is if anybody watches last program,
I was kind of zipping through it. Okay.
So things kind of slipped my mind and
then later on I was able to probably
track my mind. I went ahead of myself
and I kind of misstated one or two
things but then I was able to catch it
and and correct it later on.
>> But um but just keep that in mind
because I was somewhere else. You
remember my I was elsewhere. I was out
of state and I had to still travel home.
So I was just zipping through it. So
it's like I was going through it
[clears throat] very quick.
>> However, with that being said, I still
presented it and then I let the chips
fall where they will. And I believe that
those that did get to see it, they got
to see it in this clarity. Now, I'm
going to submit to you again, it's not
going to be easy for many of us that
held the view that it was atheism at
first to go hear this and then to easily
wrap their minds around this. I know
it's not going to be easy. Why? Because
once we have believed something in our
minds, it becomes gospel.
>> And then when we hear something else
>> and it contradicts something that we
have already believed on, believed in,
it's going to challenge us. And some of
us don't want to let go of that baby
that we had and we want to take this,
you know, take, you know, take this new
concept and as a result and and of
course what I find is that we tend to
fight it
>> and that's fine. I'm saying I'm not here
for I'm not here to to um criticize
people because they criticize me or
scrutinize what I say. That's not my
point. But you need to watch it. Don't
just write it off and say it's wrong
without watching it,
>> right?
>> You know, so let's just keep those
things in mind. All right, so let's get
right into the study. I am going to say
this in today's study though, we're
going to kind of zip through the first
beginning phases. I wanted to tackle
some more detail within the beginning
phases of Daniel chapter 11. But because
I have so much I have to deal with in
half at the halfway point and more
dealing to the final crisis because this
is what today's subject is all about. I
want I'm going to zip through the first
beginning half of it, but I'm just going
to give the anchor points so that we can
get to the latter part. Okay, so just a
little bit of a reminder right now.
Remember, as I stated before, Daniel
chapter 11 is basically the story, but
you have to go, you got to begin with
Daniel 10 because Daniel 10 is the
prelude. Daniel 11 is the story and
Daniel 12 is the conclusion. We're going
to be dealing a little bit, just tad bit
with Daniel 12 today. Not much, okay?
We're going to deal with one one verse,
one and a half verse if you will. But
we're going to deal with that later on
in the latter part of our um our subject
here today. But just remember in order
for you to get context you of Daniel
chapter 11 you got to start from Daniel
chapter 10. Unfortunately Mikey many
people start at least those from my
church and I say this lovingly we tend
to want to start from verse um 40 to 45.
>> We don't get no real context to what
happened in the past. So therefore you
can make up anything to whatever
happened in the future. Okay. So you
can't do that. You do you do yourself a
disservice whenever you do that. Okay.
So now in Daniel chapter 10, Gabriel
appears before Daniel and as I stated
previously, I'll repeat it again. The
Bible says, "And behold, a hand touched
me which set me upon my knees. And he
said unto me, oh Daniel, a man greatly
beloved, understand the words that I
speak unto thee." Now listen to what
Gabriel tells Daniel. He tells Daniel,
"Now I am come to make thee understand
what shall befall thy people in the
latter days." Latter days, last days.
Okay. So,
>> what we need to understand as a
reminder, Mikey, is that we need to
understand that this particular pro
prophecy is more so for our time than
Daniel's time. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah. The latter days. Yeah.
>> The latter days. Okay. But he's saying
his people. So, we got to understand who
are Daniel's people in the last days.
>> Let me give you one out of the two
verses that I gave previously, but I
just cuz I want to zip through it. When
you go to Romans chapter 2, 28 and 29,
Mikey, if you can be kind enough, please
read this verse, these two verses.
>> For he is not a Jew which is one
outwardly, neither is that circumcision
which is outward in the flesh. But he is
a Jew which is one inwardly and
circumcision is that of the heart in the
spirit and not of the letter who whose
praise is not of men but of God.
>> Okay. So we know that even though we're
not part of Abraham's seed by blood that
is sometimes I can even argue that with
people because I came from Adam and Eve.
I mean that's our original parents.
Right.
>> Right.
>> And from them as well. Now we do know
that God separated Abel from amongst the
heathens and everything but still we
come from the from the same bloodline.
So what I like to see when I see this
God is just grafting us back in from to
the original. Because remember in in um
when you read um um Genesis 3:15 that
was a prophecy about the coming Messiah.
And he gave that prophecy to who? To
Adam and Eve. It wasn't to Abra.
>> He gave it to Adam and Eve. So they knew
that there was a coming deliverer
[clears throat] for them.
>> Eventually God chose Abraham and he
separated that group in order to be the
depositories of his law and to teach the
world about the coming savior.
>> Unfortunately we know that they failed
in their covenant with God. And we find
that in in in Acts chapter um 5 6 7 and
then 8 and then nine. You know what
happens with Paul. Okay. Another story
for another time. Now in Daniel chapter
11, springboarding a little ver a little
bit forward with the verses, the Bible
says as follows. And the king of the
south shall be moved with caller, that's
anger, and shall come forth and fight
with him even with the king of the
north. And he shall set forth a great
multitude, but the multitude shall be
given into his hand. So obviously, and
the reason why I jump to verse 11 is
because here's when you find north and
south. North and south. Now the question
is what's north and what's south?
Remember, as I stated before, I have to
stipulate it again because this is where
a lot of people, especially from my
church, do not seem to understand that
when Daniel's given this vision, he has
given it, he's given the vision, he he
sees in a vision a geographical map to
understand what is north and what is
south. Okay. Now, so who are these north
and south kings? Well, in order to
understand this, we have to go to the
book of Jeremiah because this was
Daniel's prophet. And Jeremiah, I'm not
going to read all the verses, but it
says here, or Mikey, can you be kind
enough to read these these um three
verses, please?
>> Yeah. And the word of the Lord came unto
me the second time, saying, What seeest
thou? And I said, I see a seething pot,
and the face thereof is toward the
north. Then the Lord said unto me, "Out
of the north, an evil shall break forth
upon all the inhabitants of the land."
>> Okay, continue.
>> I don't see the next one.
>> Did it come up yet?
>> Yeah.
>> For lo, I will call all the families of
the kingdoms of the north. I noticed
you're um underline the plural plurality
there. I will call all the families of
the kingdoms of the north, sayaeth the
Lord, and they shall come, and they
shall set everyone his throne at the
entering of the gates of Jerusalem, and
against all the walls thereof
roundabout, and against all the cities
of Judah.
>> Okay. So now, you notice as you well um
stipulated, you notice that I have it
underlined, those underlined letters. I
mean when it comes to families in the
kingdoms because it's plural.
>> Okay. But you know again um Mikey from
what direction are they coming from?
>> The north.
>> The north. Now remember according to
what Jeremiah said here that evil was
going to come from that direction. Am I
right?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. So now the first empire that came
to the scene here at least in terms of
prophecy was the kingdom of Babylon. But
we know that eventually Babylon handed
the scepter over to the next rising
power which we have here that in Daniel
10 or rather Daniel 11 Babylon is never
mentioned as I mentioned before Babylon
is never mentioned from Daniel Daniel 7
on or rather is up to Daniel 7 Daniel 8
and onward Babylon is never repeated
again it's off of the it's not even
talked about those kingdoms that are
starting that the prophecy starts off
with it starts off with the kingdom of
me and the Persian where the Persian
became the dominant of the two. Now you
go to Daniel 11:2, the Bible goes on to
say, "Behold, there shall stand up in
Persia." Now, let's let's analyze the
the the terminology that is in red or in
pink there. The term stand up refers to
another king taking up the kingship. As
I stated before and I'll repeat again,
when you ever see the word stand up, the
phrase stand up is telling us that
another king, it could be within that
own kingdom
here is in the kingdom is dealing with
the kingdom of Persia or another rising
power that takes office or that takes
the baton or becomes the world empire or
eventually becomes the world empire. So
that's what it simply means. So when we
finish off, when we go a little bit
further into that verse, it says here,
"Behold, there shall stand up yet three
kings in Persia, and the fourth shall be
far richer than they all." And you
notice that it says far richer. That
person that was far richer was Xerxes
the first or Hazerus in the Bible. You
can find it in the book of Ezra and you
can also find it in the book of Esther.
Okay? That was Esther's husband. Now
when it did say here that there's the
fourth the previous three as noted
before number one was Cambiasis II King
Assyus you know King Cyrus's son smurdis
Bardija he was an impostor he didn't
last for too long and Das the first and
then you had Xerxes which was king
Hazerus now the first anchor point that
we did establish in the past was that in
Daniel 11:2A
the king of the north here was
represented as Persia okay however
However, when you go back to that verse
in verse two, the latter portion of
verse two says the following. And by his
strength, through his riches, he shall
stir up all against the realm of Grecia.
So now you see another kingdom rising to
power. I
specifically
detailed all the information concerning
this other kingdom. The Bible says, and
it gives us the the understanding that
it was referring to Alexander the
Great's empire. How do we know?
According to verse three, it says, um,
"And a mighty king shall stand up and
shall rule with great dominion." Well,
the only one that I know that's been the
greatest out of all the great, um, the
Grecian, um, leaders, everybody knows,
is Alexander the Great. I don't know of
anyone else that was greater than he in
terms of history, greatest amongst all,
right? Okay. So, we know that this
talking about the kingdom of Greece.
Okay. Now Mikey, I want you to I want
you to read the next verse that deals
with what happened with Greece after
immediately after Alexander died.
>> After he has appeared, his empire shall
be broken up and parcled out toward the
four winds of heavens.
It of heaven. It will not go to his
descendants nor will it have the power
he exercised because his empire will be
uprooted and given to others.
>> The others were the four generals of
Alexander the Great. Okay, these were
the four other I mean the others that it
was given to. And remember it did not go
to his descendants just as history has
stated. Now this is very interesting.
This prophecy came out way before
Alexander was ever born.
So that's amazing how God could predict
things before they happen. Wouldn't you
agree?
>> Amen.
>> So you have the four generals of
Alexander here
that basically split the kingdom in
half. It was a massive civil war as you
see depicted in that four-headed
leopard. Remember heads represents
kings. So there was four kings out of
one nation, one leopard which was a
representation of the kingdom of Greece.
Now it's very interesting. One thing
that I'm going to quote here from a book
that I have at home that I didn't quote
in our pre our past two previous um
sessions. I want you to notice what this
book entitled Alexander the Great from
Philip Freeman had to say on page 321.
This is what he says. One outcome of the
meeting meeting was a division of the
empire. Tommy received Egypt while
Salucas would hold the bulk of Asia.
Cassander would retain Macedonia in
Greece and the king's former bodyguard
Lysmicus would take over Thrace. Many
people don't know that that was that
[clears throat] um Lysmicus was his
bodyguard but eventually became a king.
So now when you look at these four
kings, the Bible is not going to focus
on all four of them. The fi the Bible
what he's what what Daniel 11 is going
to do from this point on is focus on the
two latter ones. That's salucas and
salucas and talamy. So that would make
it then if you look at the three and the
number four the salutes will be to the
north and the tameics will be to the
south. North and south from this point
on in the bible those are the only two
kings or within their jurisdictions that
the bible focuses on until the next
rising power takes you know possession.
So when you look at the map, remember in
order for Daniel to understand what
Gabriel's stating, he has to look at a
map and understand what's north and
what's south. So what he came to find
out soluces to the north and the
talamies to the south or the talome is
to the south. Now Mikey, I asked this
question several times before. I'll re
ask this question to you. Who gets stuck
in the middle?
>> Jerusalem.
>> Jerusalem. Very good. Which is God's
people? Remember the issue or the point
that Gabriel was going was trying to
stress to Daniel was that listen I want
you to know there's going to be a lot of
problems a lot of wars but your people
are always going to c be caught in the
middle until the end of time. Does that
make sense?
>> No.
>> Okay. Now but did the prophecy or rather
did the um Grecian Empire last forever?
>> No
>> it did not. Right? Because when you
continue to look at it, the Bible says
in in Daniel 11:14-16.
Now, there are people that tend to
believe that Rome probably came in that,
you know, some previous chapters. Well,
according to my study and based upon
what I've come to to understand, um,
William Sha was very good with some um,
noting this down. I appreciate his work.
Um, he noted that it was 14 where you
see Rome coming into action. Now, and
the Bible says here, "And in those times
there shall there I'm sorry, there shall
many stand up against the king of the
south." Remember, stand up mean, you
know, a new king rising to power. So,
let's look at the anchor points slide.
First, we had Persia. Then, now we had
Greece coming into play. Now, this is
what was happening there. But let's now
go to verse 16. In verse 16, okay, the
Bible goes goes on to say, "And he that
cometh against him shall do according to
his own will, and none shall stand
before him, and he shall stand in the
glorious land by which by which by his
hand shall be consumed." Now, Mikey, I I
didn't do it here. I probably should
have submitted another slide here, but
that glorious land is mentioned back in
Daniel 8:9.
No one can really dispute, at least
people that hold to the true meaning of
what Daniel 8:9 is referring to. That's
talking about Palestine, Judea, if you
will. So notice it says he. Now remember
that I said before, the one that is
highlighted in red represents the kings
to the north, which is of course Rome
here in this case. And then of course
the one that is in blue, highlighted in
blue, that's the one referring to the
king of the south. So when you look at
the geographical map, you have Jerusalem
right there. And of course, there's
something there's a power that's coming
that's coming to being. It was Greece at
first, but eventually Rome starts to
take the baton. Then springboarding to
verse 20. 20 really locks it in. There's
no mistake of what kingdom is the ruling
faction of this time. If anybody wants
to dispute anything before, that's fine.
But you cannot dispute this. And by the
way, we can prove this out of the word
of God. Mikey, go ahead and read this
verse.
Then shall stand up in his estate a
razor of taxes in the glory of the
kingdom, but within a few days he shall
be destroyed neither in anger nor in
battle.
>> So when you look at this text, Mikey,
what do we come to find out? Or what
empire was ruling at this particular
time?
>> Uh the yeah the Caesar or Rome.
>> Yes, Rome. Remember we confirmed it with
the nativity story. Go ahead and read
this verse.
>> And it came to pass in those days that
there went out a decree from Caesar
Augustus that all the world should be
taxed.
>> That all the world should be taxed. So
we found a match to Daniel 11 20. So
we're in sync. And if you notice in the
previous chapters, you have the first
kingdom that rises to power Babylon.
Second is middle Persia. then Greece
which is the third and then fourth you
have pagan Rome so it was always in sync
okay we don't ever leave this type of
order
>> Daniel 2 Daniel 7 Daniel 8 and Daniel 11
repeats itself very interesting now in
Daniel 11:22
the Bible introduces us to another
specific person a very important person
a person that should be the focus of our
attention from the sometimes his past,
even to our future. The Bible says here,
"And with the arms of flood, they should
shall be overflown from before him and
shall be broken. Yay, also the prince of
the covenant." Now Mikey asked the
question before, who is this prince of
the covenant?
>> Is this Jesus?
>> Prince.
>> Jesus Christ. Very good. Now, I didn't
talk about it, but when we when we when
we deal with the Daniel chapter 7, it's
very interesting. That word prince here,
you only find it in one other place. You
know where you find it at? In Daniel
chapter 9. And do you know that people
try to use that covenant issue about
remember the antichrist?
>> They say it's the antichrist.
>> Exactly. But this is the only time that
you find that word there
>> messiah.
>> You find
the exactly the only other time that you
find that same exact Hebrew word. Okay.
Is in Daniel chapter 9. Very
interesting. But we'll get into that.
Deal with Daniel chapter um nine. That's
in connection to Daniel chapter 8. Okay.
Now, if this verse is dealing with Jesus
the Christ, the Bible then goes on to
say that he was broken. In other words,
he was killed or destroyed. So, did
Jesus ever die? Was he ever destroyed
per se?
>> Yep. On the cross.
>> He did on the cross. Now, Daniel chapter
9 vers 25 and 26 says, "Messiah the
prince shall be cut off." That means he
died. Now, Mikey, let me ask you this
question. Did he die because of his sins
or did he die because of yours? of my
sins.
>> He died because of ours.
>> He died because of my ours. So now we
know that the Romans did not care for
Christianity. Therefore, at the time of
Jesus's death, paganism was against true
Christianity. Would you agree with that?
>> Yep.
>> But let me ask you something. Is Jesus
our future king?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, he is. Right. So, there is a war
and people don't understand that there's
a true war that's taking place. Okay.
Now,
if Jesus was destroyed, did Christianity
lose though?
>> No,
>> it didn't. Remember 3 days later, which
we just celebrated, you know, the the
Easter weekend, as come call it,
>> um Jesus was resurrected on what we call
the first day of the week.
>> So, you know, we know that he and I have
to say, praise be to God because
prophecy was being fulfilled. Amen.
>> Amen.
But right, but after he left, I mean
after he sorry, after he resur he was
resurrected, remember he gave the great
commission. And go ahead and read that.
Um, brother Mikey, what was the great
commission?
>> Go ye therefore and teach all nations,
baptizing them in the name of the Father
and of the Son and of the Holy Ghost,
teaching them to observe all things
whatsoever I have commanded you.
>> Okay. Thank you. Now, let me pause for a
second. Um Mikey, I have to I'm going to
make this point here. Some people will
say, "Well, Ernest, why are you going
over going over this ground?" I like the
concept that um Leslie, Dr. Leslie
Harding said at one time. He says,
"Repetition deepens the impression."
You get it? Repetition repeated and
often deepens his understanding. And
many of us, including myself, I need to
hear it several times to get it. You get
what I'm saying? And this helps out
those that can't quite get it as other
people can. So, I'm doing it for them as
well. If you're one of those that don't
like to hear things repeated often, then
I'm sorry. This might not be the
platform for you. But I'm doing it.
>> And Mikey, I'm going to say something.
>> I've gotten people to tell me that they
have learned so much from these
particular studies, especially on study
number one, because they never
understood it as opposed to how they saw
it and how I explained it from A to Z.
>> Yeah. In our first meeting, I I tried to
do the best that I could do to break it.
I could still do it do it even further,
but for the sake of time, I can only
give what I gave. But people were very
much appreciated. And I say, praise be
to God. This is all God's work. Okay.
Amen. Now, let's so we know then
Christianity started to flourish
according to acts 8 2 and 4. And they
went everywhere preaching the word of
God. And this is the unadulterated
word of God. This was the truth. So this
was Q Christianity. the spread of true
Christianity. But what was the
jurisdiction under this Christianity? It
was Rome. Are you getting this?
>> Yeah.
>> So Rome, remember paganism was against
Rome. I mean true Christianity. So there
was a fight if you will for the throne
of people's hearts. Okay? And at that
time up to this point we're going to hit
the anchor point. So again we got
Greece. Now we got pagan Rome. We
already supplanted that by this point by
verse 22. We get pagan Rome which is
switching. This is during the still the
time of pagan Rome. Okay, no one can
dispute that or they too they do they
bring their own reasons and that's fine.
Okay.
>> Now
from 22 on rather from 23 on
Christianity starts to decline
let's read let's read these particular
verses. It says here and after the
league made with him now their nearest
antecedent to the hymn is none other
than the prince of the covenant. So it's
talking about Christianity if you will.
>> So a league, some type of contract that
was made, something that was in
agreement,
>> was made, remember this is the north
shall work what? Deceitfully.
>> Deceitfully.
>> You can't say that that's how true
Christianity operates,
>> right?
>> So something happened to the decline of
Christianity. And it goes on to say, for
the king of the south, he, that's what
it's representing, shall come up and
shall become strong with us small
people. He shall enters peaceibly even
upon the fattest places of the province.
And he shall do that which his fathers
have not done, nor his father's fathers.
He shall scatter among them the prey,
the spoil riches. Yay. And he shall
forecast his devices against the
strongholds for a time. Now I asked a
question previously the past two
previous two previous times. I'll repeat
the question. Mikey, did a certain form
of Christianity work deceitfully and do
that which his fathers have not done nor
his father's father? In other words, his
ancestors.
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay. What was that?
>> Roman Catholicism.
>> What was the
>> Roman Catholicism? That's was the church
that combined paganism and Christianity
together thus corrupting the church.
>> We're going to understand this today.
We're going to go further today in some
point that I'm going to draw that I
never discussed before. And this is
going to really open the minds to a lot
of people. You're going to see this for
the first time also for yourself,
brother Mikey, and your listeners as
well. So again, we're looking at the
geographical map. You have peopleled
Christianity to the north. This is the
Roman Empire. Now, if you take Daniel
7's um beast, the terrible and dreadful
beast with 10 horns, iron teeth, and he
stamped the residue with the feet of it
with the with the mouth of it. We know
that eventually pagan Rome hands his
over his scepter over to paple Rome.
that little horn that came up after the
temp that uprooted three previous ones
had eyes like the eyes of a man and a
mouth speaking great things. We'll get
to that in just a bit. Okay. So, we have
established here Daniel seeing a power
to the north. Remember the dividing line
is Jerusalem. But then at during this
time that um pap or Roman Catholicism
starts small but eventually it grows
into a great power that this is within a
thousand year on time bracket.
Something's happening when the south is
well.
Let's read what the Bible says here.
Mike, be kind enough to read this one as
well, please.
>> And he shall stir up his power and his
courage against the king of the south,
with a great army, and the king of the
south shall be stirred up to battle with
a very great and mighty army. But he
shall not stand, for they shall forecast
devices against him.
Okay. So, you notice there's issues that
arising from the north and now there is
battles happening and transpiring with
the south. But I want you to notice
[clears throat]
what it says here. It says that it shall
stir up I mean I'm sorry and his power
and his courage shall against the king
of the south with a great army and the
king of the south shall stir up the
battle with a very great and mighty
army. So obviously the tensions are
rising and they're mounting up great
military might both ends. That is
>> we got to think about in history because
everything else was historical. This has
to be something that we point to in
history. Now what was the specific
country that we last unsaid in our
previous meetings remember said to be
the kingdom south. A specific location
started with E. South of Jerusalem. What
was it again?
>> It was very good. Egypt. Now folks, let
me be very clear. Nowhere's in the book
of Daniel does it ever say spiritually
Egypt. If you find it, let me know
because I've never found it. D and when
I made it clear, Daniel 11 has nothing
to do with Daniel I mean Revelation 11.
That has we're trying to bring them
together. That's not what you have here.
That's not what this is talking about.
>> But but let me go. Okay. Now, and I
established that point in our last
meeting at the latter part of our
meeting. All right. In Daniel 11:es 5-8,
D um brother, can you please read that
now? And the king of the south shall be
strong, and the south shall come to the
king of the north, and shall also carry
captives into Egypt, and he shall
continue more years than the king of the
north. Okay? So, you notice you have
Egypt there. You notice there's south,
there's you notice that there's north.
And you notice that they will continue
more more year. They were going to
continue on. Why? Because these battles
are taking place. But what the Bible
does right now is give us more
information. Before we go into that
added [clears throat] information
question during the years of the rise of
the civil and religious or the state in
um the church and state power which is
Roman Catholicism which is considered
the king of the north did the king of
the south which is Egypt which we have a
location transition itself to becoming a
different civil and religious entity as
well. What do you think or we covered it
already? The answer to that is yes
>> added information given to us in verses
25 to 27. And he shall stir up his
power, the king of the north, peopleled
Christianity, and his courage against
the king of the south with a great army.
We cover that. And the great I mean
sorry, and the king of the south shall
be stirred up to battle with a very
great and mighty army. But he shall not
stand, but they shall for devices
against him. Yay, they that feed of the
portion of the of his meat shall shall
destroy him, and his army shall
overflow, and many shall fall down
slain. Many battles took place. We
understood who this the identity of the
king of the south was. But just to
understand this a little bit further,
Mikey,
I read this twice before. I'm going to
go tad bit in further into it. The Bible
says, "And both these kings heart shall
be to do mischief, and they shall speak
lies at one table, but it shall not
prosper. For yet the end shall be at the
pointed time, at the time appointed."
That that last part of the phrase is
very key. The end shall be at the
appointed time. The end. I want you to
understand it. End. Time of the end,
>> right?
>> And that's at specific time. Did you get
it? This is where people lose this. They
lose this clause. They think that it's
something. No, you this clause is very
important with another clause we're
going to talk about as well just
momentarily. Now,
where it says here that these both these
kings, the kings of the north, king of
the south, they'll do mischief.
Obviously, you cannot trust them. And it
says they'll speak lies on one table.
This is basically stating that whenever
these two kingdoms are fighting and
trying to call it quits and trying to
just bring some resolve, they'll try to
make a pack. They tried to make some
truses. Now, the truses that we came to
was during the time period of the
Crusades.
Okay, it was the time period the
Crusades and we know that it could only
be the only only opponent for the
Crusades that was that had a great and
mighty army. Looking at the map, this is
what Daniel's looking at. He sees the
king to the north, people Christianity
during this time period. Who's the only
other power that could have a great and
mighty army during this time period? It
is none other than Islam.
>> Okay? It was a religious political power
as well. So you have a church and state
power to the north and you have a church
and state power to the south. You notice
that?
>> Right.
>> Okay. And they get corrupted as a result
because the church runs the state.
>> Yeah. Mhm.
>> Who gets caught in the middle then?
[snorts] Um, Brother Mikey,
>> who gets what? Huh?
>> Who gets caught in the middle?
>> Oh, Jerusalem again.
>> God's people, right? It will be like
that throughout the rest of Daniel
chapter 11. It will always be that way.
Okay? Because these two forces that
would never agree with each other until
Jesus. They will never agree with with
each other. There's just no way. They
might come to a pack because to, you
know, to some advantages that they have
to, you know, meet with, but in reality,
they can't stand each other.
You follow what I'm saying? Now, let's
go back to this text. I'm I'm going to
go I'm going to hammer a little bit.
When it says that both these kings will
speak lies on one table, remember
they're trying to make covenants.
They're trying to make agreements.
They're trying to call call some peace.
This is some of the list of times that
truses were made and subsequently broken
and reiged. Remember it says here, speak
lies at one table. Let me give you the
list of them. This is just several of
them, okay? And this is during the time
period of the crusades. You have the
breach of surrender on terms at ma mara
in 1098. You had rain of challen
chat le I'm sorry chat [laughter]
ton
attack on caravan and I believe that was
the children's crusade that's what they
called the children's crusade 1187 then
you had the treaty of jaffa and treaty
of ramla in 1192 and the treaty of 12 um
29 to 1239. Now, one of these, this the
third one that you see there is the one
that dealt with Salad Salah. Saladan
very important character one of which
today the Islamic world wants to bring
in another Saladan or Salahaden as they
call it. Now it's very interesting.
Salahadin
the Kaulifhats during that time period
they had two locations but the main one
was in Cairo Egypt that was their hub
that was their capital if you will and
it was more because of the economic
reasons behind it but that's that was
their political capital if you will but
let's just continue to move forward. Let
me go ahead and play this clip that I
played before. And again I'm only using
the clip just to confirm this. I'm not
the only one that believes this, but
this clip just helps to further the
point. Okay? And I shared with it the
last two presentation. I'm going to
repeat it again.
But I think of all the wars fought over
religion, the Crusades belong in their
own category.
By the end of the 11th century, 600
years after the fall of Rome, the two
religions are great rivals.
Christianity dominates in the west and
north,
Islam in the east [music] and south.
Now Mikey, I'm pausing it here, but you
notice you had Roman Catholics and
Christianity to the north and west and
you had Islam to the south and east.
>> Just like the Bible's already mentioned.
And by the way,
>> History Channel was not trying to quote
the Bible. I promise you, they were not
even trying [laughter] to get close.
This is the same channel that this is
the same channel that tells us that the
uh
>> pyramids were built by aliens and that
aliens seeded life here on Earth and
everything. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yes. And a lot of other things.
And I have, you know, I'm going to tell
you something. Sometimes they tell you
throw some good stuff too that confirms
what we believe. Right.
>> Right. Yeah.
>> You can here and there too. You know
what I'm saying? Let me go on.
Determined to curb the advance of Islam,
the Pope calls on Christians to take up
arms.
Their target, the holy city of
Jerusalem.
On the eve of the Crusades, Jerusalem
under Muslim rule was actually a hotbed
of creativity and interreligious
dialogue. There were Jews, there were
Christians, there were Muslims. [music]
For the most part, they lived in
relative harmony.
But each lays claim [music] to the city.
Jews rever it as their ancient capital.
Muslims know it as Alkutz, the holy.
From here, the prophet Muhammad
journeyed to heaven.
And for Christians,
Christ was crucified here.
It's amazing when you go to Jerusalem,
if you just stop for a second,
you'll see that these people actually
have more in common than they have that
are differences.
They are the sons and daughters of
Abraham.
[music]
to all who join the crusade. Pope Urban
offers eternal salvation.
>> Now listen to what Pope Urban says. This
is the pope. Now I have the quotation
before, but sometimes for um and how
should I say um for video purposes, I'm
trying to help people to see that this
is not something that you can you can
read it in the book, but look at even
his history channel has his right. I
just have to give it to you. declaring,
"The Lord beseeches you to destroy that
vile race from the lands of our
friends."
>> I want you to notice, Mikey, another
point, too, that you notice the language
that Pope Urban II, the Christians
using.
>> What is that?
>> To stamp out this vow race. To stamp out
this vow race, right?
>> Very interesting. You're gonna you're
going to hear something like this later
on in our presentation. I mean not
exactly like that but you're going to
see it's basically it's it's the bas the
same narrative if you will
>> because there a lot of people from the
west Christians that is view Islamic
countries that are radicals that way as
well right
>> okay we'll get that in just a bit
>> all who die by the way shall have
immediate remission of sins
>> a knight could sin as much as he liked
and simply by going to the holy land he
had been given forgiveness by the pope.
He had been given his passport to
heaven. He could win fame. He could win
glory. And he could come back with
booty.
It is one of the most shameful
undertakings ever embarked upon by our
species.
>> Okay. But that's very clear. We
established that point before. So by
1099, I'm sorry. By 1099, the crusaders
finally conquered Jerusalem. Okay. So,
they held that seat, that throne if you
will, in Jerusalem until you had Saladin
that came back and took it.
>> That's why they hated and meant and let
me tell you something. If you read this
story about King Baldwin, believe it was
King Baldwin the fourth, you will find
out what truly they literally the
crusaders took, you know how, let let me
give it to you this way. Remember Mikey,
the story about the Israelites when they
were lead the stories leading all the
way up to the priest Eli. Remember Eli's
two sons and Samuel. And remember that
they used the ark of the covenant as a
relic, as a a virtue to save them
instead of relying upon God. Remember
that,
>> right? Yeah.
>> Did something like that. You know what
they did? They erected a great big
golden cross, a cross, a cross of
Christ. They were travel with it
>> less like the ark of the covenant. And
they believe that that relic was the one
to Saber whenever they went to battles.
>> But they [clears throat] lost that
relic. Salahim was able to take take
control of that cross and it was a big
blow a moral blow to the crusaders. Read
about it. It was more horrific for them
because they felt like you know like the
glory of the Lord departed from them.
Look at history. You you wise about it.
But anyways let's move forward.
>> In verse 29 is very key. In verse 29 it
says here and at that at the time
appointed here you have the word time
appointed he shall return and come
toward the south and but it shall not be
as the former that means what we just
read up to to that point that we read or
as the latter meaning the next or
following because the word next can also
mean the following or the the subsequent
one that's that we're going to be
talking about. Now according to this
text there are three phases not one not
two but three phases dealing with the
king of the north and the king of the
south. As mentioned before, I'll I'll
state it again. The first phase of Rome
or this conquest was found in the latter
part of that verse, the former. The
second is the latter which we are about
to speak on. And then finally, the third
and final will be the one in verse 40.
That's what we establish. In other
words, there is unfinished business.
So what this is telling us is that from
vers 23 all the way to verse 29 you will
find that this was an external phase of
Rome people Christianity they had to
deal with the conquest of these um um
Christian sites that they wanted to
conquer but who it was in the hands of
the um um um Arabs or Islam Islamic
countries
>> right
>> and it was a big battle in the crusade
um time period. Okay. So, it was battle
after battle after battle. So, this was
the external phase or this was the the
first formal phase. But the Bible's
going to kind of
turn the page if you will, so that they
can show you something that was taking
place internally. So, what was the next
or following issue that the papacy had
to face? Remember that was the external
problem, the civil arena. Now, they're
going to have to deal with the internal
arena. Mhm.
>> Now the internal arena had to deal with
the reformation. Again, we established
this point. Just repetition deepens the
impression. Okay. What does Daniel say
transpired during this second phase of
paper Christianity? Well, something else
that I'm about to share with you,
brother, because we do know, I mean,
it's clear. Oh, what did I do? We do
know that paperled Christianity um was
killing people, killing God's people.
Remember that? Remember Martin Luther?
>> Okay. Mhm.
>> And um you know deal with con. So we
covered that already. But this is
another section, brother Mikey, that I
did not cover before. And check this
out. And I'm sure you're going to agree
with this. This is a verse that I
skipped over the past pre two previous
lectures. This time I'm going to go into
it. I want you to notice something that
takes place here. Okay? Right after that
verse, I want you to notice in verse 31
what it says here. Now go ahead and read
verse 31. and arms shall stand on his
part, and they shall pollute the
sanctuary of strength, and shall take
away the daily sacrifice, and they shall
place the abomination that maketh
desolate.
Now, let's cover the word sacrifice.
Anytime in the King James Bible, you see
some word italicized, that means that
the word has been added, okay? In order
to make sense of the text. Unfortunately
though, and hear me clearly for those
that are listening. Unfortunately,
that word there sacrifice should not be
applied next to the terminology or the
word daily. Why? Because in cultic
language, when I say cultic cultic, I'm
referring to religious language that
word that if you apply the word
sacrifice to the word daily in
connection to it, you limit the term of
daily. Why? Because when you read the
word daily, you understand that have to
deal with the sanctuary. The what?
>> The sanctuary.
>> The sanctuary. Now you notice it says
here and his part, meaning the king of
the north, he shall pollute the what?
The sanctuary of strength.
>> When you look into the word strength is
actually renders off to being the
sanctuary of rock. Who is your rock?
>> Christ.
>> That's what this is referring to. M
>> the sanctuary of
>> where's Christ's sanctuary at the time
of paper Christianity
>> in heaven
>> in heaven so you see something taking
place here
>> something is something is going on with
now and this is why I said now this is
the internal issue the Bible's telling
us that now Roman Catholicism and the
state which here was the king of Clovis
that is they join hands in other words
it was a amalgamated
>> and thus and this in the year 508 508
okay not 538 508 this is where Daniel
chapter 9 goes and gives us um two other
time periods we'll get into that later
not to anybody okay but this was in 508
AD so now you have the emergence of
church and state combined okay and it
says it will take away the daily
remember the word sacrifice it limits
the word daily
>> what do I mean let's get into
Have we ever read or seen somewhere else
that paperled Christianity would take
away the daily? Yes, we did. Now, in
Daniel chapter 8, what what where did I
say?
>> What did you say?
>> Daniel chapter Daniel chapter 8. This is
why I say Daniel chapter 8 goes with
Daniel chapter 11
>> because you you you read the same
verbiage. Now, Daniel chapter 8, I want
you to notice, go ahead and read that.
>> And a little horn magnified himself,
even to the prince of the host, and by
him the daily sacrifice was taken away,
and the place of his sanctuary was cast
down.
>> Now, we got to understand what is this
word daily? What? Because many people
don't know what the word daily is. We
need to understand and comprehend what
did this little horn do during the dark
ages that he took away something. You
notice the prince of the host. The
prince of the host. This prince of the
host is none other than Jesus Christ as
you can see here. Now remember that's
symbolic imagery. Okay. And you see that
it magnified himself. Now it's very
interesting. You have this this has to
be Roman Catholicism because when you
read when you read um in the latter part
of Daniel chapter 11, we we read this um
um some time before, but remember this
the statement here. Read that right
there in verse 36.
>> And the king shall do according to his
will and he shall exalt himself and
magnify himself above every god and
shall speak marvelous things against the
God of gods.
>> So are we talking about the same entity
here? Of course we are.
>> Yeah, the little horn.
>> Of course we are. But the thing is this
has to deal with the sanctuary. Remember
this. The sanctuary of strength, the
sanctuary of rock, the sanctuary of
Christ. He takes away the daily. Daily
is not just a sacrifice. It's sacrifice
and much more when it comes to the
sanctuary. So what do what does this all
mean? What is the daily in the context
of Daniel 8:11 and 11:31 referring to?
But for your listeners and for you
Mikey, you're going to learn something
in Daniel chapter 11:31. It ties it to
Daniel chapter 8 vers 11. And there was
attack on God's holy sanctuary up in
heaven. But the way to understand that
is to study the one here on earth.
Remember the Mosaic sanctuary, the one
that was um it was a um it was
transferable. In other words, it was a
tent that they can break down and moved
around for 40 years. Remember that
>> there were three apartments. Remember
there was three apartments. You had the
courtyard which is out there which had
the altar and or rather the the altar of
sacrifice and then you had the labor the
wash. I get to that just a bit. And then
when you were to go into the holy place
and the most holy place you will have
let me have it here. Let me do it here.
You have the holy place and then you
have most holy place. Now let me deal
with the word daily.
Every day. What did I say? Um Mikey.
>> Every day.
>> Every day. The priests would always do a
sacrifice morning and evening be when
they started their services between as
well, but they will also close it. They
would hold their sacrifice and you see
that if you look in to the center of
that picture, you see a priest at the
wash bowl, the labor. You see that
there?
>> Yeah.
>> The priest will first actually go there,
wash his hands, wash his feet before he
does anything in the sanctuary. Thus, he
was being consecrated to officiate in
the sanctuary for the Lord. Does that
make sense?
>> Yeah.
daily that will go on. You see, when you
limit the word and when you when you
apply the word sacrifice, it would not
then include the labor or other things
that I'm about to just um um address.
Okay? So, daily they would do these
things. So, it's not just a sacrifice.
So, when you see the word here, let me
go back to it. When you see the word
sacrifice in this text, it's added. So
when the translators brought it or
rather included it in the text,
obviously it was not part of the
original, but they could trying to make
sense of it, you got to think about the
reformation period. You got to think
about the time of the dark ages. They
didn't have a fullblown understanding on
what these conscious are because why?
The Catholic Church obscured it from the
people. How?
>> By taking the word of God from them. Yes
or no?
>> Yep.
>> So that's what we're going to get into.
And and this is what took place during
the dark ages. So internally in the
church they remember they were working
deceitfully. So let's start off with the
altar of sacrifice. This was the daily
ritual. The daily ritual as we just um
dealt with it rather that we just um
understood had to deal with them
bringing a sacrifice. Right? I want you
to notice Mikey look at your screen.
This is what they ancient Israel used to
do. But look at what Catholicism did by
desecrating this or by altering its
meaning. When you look at this picture,
what do you see here?
>> Uh that's Catholic mass.
>> Transantiation if you were,
>> right?
>> They make the blessings. They tell
people and they believe that's the dogma
to their church. They believe that that
wafer
>> represents the actual body of Christ,
not a symbol,
>> right? But the actual body of Christ.
Therefore, during the dark ages, if you
said something different, did you know
that some people were um burnt at the
stake as a result?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> That's what happened. And the wine that
represents his blood, they said, "No,
this is actually his blood." And I'm
just putting it in layman's terms. So,
you notice that he took away the daily,
the meaning of it. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> The daily. This was part of the daily.
See, if you limit it only to sacrifice,
you're not going to get it. Well, how
about the washing of the labor daily?
They will wash their hands and their
feet morning and evening and throughout
the day they will daily they would do
it. Now, let's see. Do we have a
counterfeit for this? What's this that
you see on your screen?
>> I'm not even sure another
>> that's baptistry. Yes.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Whatever. How about whenever they
baptize people, what do they use? They
use that for
>> sprinkle. Very good. They took away its
meaning. In other words, they corrupted
it. Do you understand what was taking
place during this time period? This is
what the Bible is trying to unveil to
the people that this church became so
corrupted they took the minds away from
Christ in the sanctuary above and now
have people focus on the priests on on
earth.
>> Yeah.
>> You get it?
>> How about this picture here? You see
that?
>> He took away the daily.
>> Okay. Now let's go into the tent where
we're going to go into the holy place
and then of course the most holy place.
Now here the curtain you can't the
curtain is open and you can see the most
holy place and to the right but in the
holy place when the priest will walk
right into the sanctuary. He will look
to his left which was actually to the
south which was the candlestick or what
we call the manora. It was a seven
branch candlestick. We can talk about
all of this in the specifics. I'm
telling you it's marvelous. Marvelous.
Whenever I talk about the sanctuary,
it's one of the best redemption stories
you ever want to hear. And most people
don't even know it to this day. Why?
Because that church obscured it from the
minds of the people.
>> Because instead of pointing to Christ or
what's in the heavenly sanctuary, they
said, "No, we're your priests and you
follow us." You get it, Mikey?
>> Yeah.
>> In this in this um um the the second
apartment or what we call the holy
place, you had the candlestick of the
mura to your left, which was to the
south. Then to the north you had um the
um what did you have there?
>> To the to which way?
>> To the right. To the right. When you
walk in you have to place.
>> Yes. No the No, the holy place.
>> Oh the holy place.
>> So if the candlesticks to your left
what's to your right?
>> I don't know my what I see on the right
is the most holy place. But
>> table. Okay. To the you see the the
bread the loaves of bread. It's the
showbread. Yeah. Show bread was the
forever bread of the ever um showing
bread that will always be on the table,
>> right?
>> No time at no time. They could have that
table empty.
>> Always was supposed to be loaves of
bread. That bread will last for one week
and then we'll replace it with another
um 12 loaves.
>> Mhm.
>> Now it's very interesting. And then you
had the altar of vinces. We're going to
cover this just a bit. Okay. So let's
deal with the table showbread, the bread
of his presence. That is okay. Let's
see. And we kind of already alluded to
that earlier. Let's see we find a
counterfeit. You find a counterfeit
there.
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> That's mentioned. And you notice that
the priests are the ones that that
offer. Whenever I do communion service,
I go and I take it from the person. The
person doesn't give it to me or put it
or put it on my mouth, if you will.
>> Okay. So, he took away the daily. He
took away the in other words this was an
obstruction of what God had pointed out
in the Bible in the book of Leviticus
and how they were supposedly carried
out. Now remember the dogmas of the
church have been altered. In other
words, altered from its actual meaning.
Let's look at the seven branch
candlestick.
Now this is not too much of nobody can
really say there's so much of a how
should I say um a doing away with it.
But I just thought it was very
interesting they have their own
candlestick. He has his own candlestick
there. I just thought it was very
interesting. Not much to take out of
that one. Very interesting. But if you
don't, but if that might not be much to
you, the next will the altar Vincent.
Now, what did the
>> Mikey what did the altar vinc
represented?
>> Prayers going up.
>> For the who? For who?
>> For the people that needed the
forgiveness. Yeah.
>> People. So the priest had a sensor
golden sensor which he took he took the
coals from the altar of sacrifice
outside. He place it in the sensor. Then
he will go to the altar of incense.
He'll place the sensor on top of it. And
then he will apply frankincense. This is
the aroma if you will. Okay? He will
place it together. And once it starts to
burn, obviously the smoke will start to
ascend. The smoke represented the
prayers of the saints. The prayers of
you and I. I want you to think about
this. I want you to think about this.
You see what they did there? Look at the
Catholic Church.
>> Oh yeah.
>> You see it there?
>> Yep. They swing that incense around.
>> But you said that represented the what?
>> The prayers of the people.
>> Okay. So, let's see if they found a
counterfeit.
What's this?
>> The confessional booth.
>> You see, they took away the daily. Did
you get it?
>> Yeah.
>> They took away the daily. Everything
that pointed to Christ and his ministry,
what he was doing in heaven, they said,
"Nah, forget that. We're going to bring
it down here and you guys are going to
look up to us.
>> Why do people professional boxes to
speak to men and to convey their sins to
men? No man can forgive you of your
sins. But because the Catholic church
teaches their subjects that they are
allowed to do that and remember their
church is above the Bible, people have
been misled since the dark ages.
>> They took away the daily. They took away
the daily. Now, now you understand this
text here in Daniel 8:12.
>> Mhm. No, in Daniel 11, I'm sorry. But
over here in verse 12, this is a new
verse. I'm sorry. And a host was given.
Now, I want you to notice, a host was
given him. Remember, there was a league
made with him by small people. A host
was given him against the daily
sacrifice by reason of transgression.
And it cast down the what?
>> Truth.
>> What did it cast down?
>> The truth to the ground.
>> And it did what?
>> And it practiced and prospered.
>> Mikey, I want you to notice what the
Bible's telling us. what Roman Catholic
Catholicism did. Remember folks, we're
not talking about the people. I believe
there were many innocent people that
were misled even to this day. So, we're
not talking about people. We're talking
about the institution. I was born in
this church. I come from this church.
So, I'm not throwing any stones to any
church member by no means. I'm just
giving you the truth of the matter. Now,
what was this truth that was cast down
to the ground? Mikey, I want you to I'm
going to let the Bible speak for itself.
Okay?
In Psalms 119 verse42, what does it say
there?
>> Thy righteousness is an everlasting
righteousness, and thy law is the truth.
Oh yeah.
>> Did they cast down the the law to the
ground?
>> They sure did.
>> Okay. How about this one in verse 151?
Read that one.
>> It says, "Thou art near, O Lord, and all
thy commandments are truth."
>> Did you get it? So they cast down the
truth to the ground and practice and
prosper. This is why Daniel 8 also goes
with Daniel chapter 11. Very
interesting. So this is something added
that I know something that I added in
today's presentation. Now let's look at
verse 28. And he shall return to his
land with great riches. We covered this
I believe the last time but now I'm just
going to repeat it. And his heart was
shall be against the holy covenant. I
don't know if you remember that.
>> We dealt with that very briefly. The
holy covenant. And he should do export
because now this is the second phase.
Remember this is the other phase. Okay.
The internal problem. Okay. He goes
against his heart is against the holy
covenant. What is the holy covenant?
Please read this. You read this last
time. Let's read it again. Go ahead and
read it.
>> For this is the covenant that I will
make with the house of Israel after
those days, sayeth the Lord. I will put
my laws into their minds and write them
in their hearts. and I will be to them a
god and they shall be to me a people.
>> So did people let Christianity go
against the holy covenant of God?
>> Absolutely.
>> It did. Right. Now go ahead and see for
us to understand that that law is holy.
What does it say here?
>> Wherefore the law is holy and the
commandment holy and just and good.
>> So I'm giving you Bible evidence,
brother. This was peopleled Christianity
that did all that. And in Daniel chapter
7, remember it says, "And he shall speak
great words against the most high and
shall think to change." And he shall
think to change what?
>> Times and laws.
>> Yeah.
>> If you go to the Catholic Cal Catholic
convert catechism, um, Catholic
doctrine, I presented this the last time
I'm presented again. Which is the
Sabbath day? Saturday is the Sabbath
day. They tell you which is a Sabbath
day. They're not ashamed to tell you.
Why do we observe Sunday instead of
Sabbath? They'll give you the answer.
Roman Catholic Church [snorts] will tell
you. Because the Catholic Church
transferred, that's another word for
change, the semity, that's another word
for the seriousness, from Saturday to
Sunday. Interesting. The Bible predicted
it before it happened in Daniel 7:2. And
he shall think to change times and laws.
So obviously they abregated the law of
God. And what did they do with the
calendar?
>> Instead of Saturday being the holy day
of God, they said, "No, let's make it
official
being the first day of the week."
>> Right?
>> That was very
And now watch this because this is
another piece that I did not share with
you guys last time. In the book of
Revelation, where are we going to um um
brother?
>> The book of Revelation.
>> I want you to read this because John the
Revelator sees a woman sees a woman in
vision. What does it say here?
>> And there appeared a great wonder in
heaven and a woman clothed with the sun.
>> Now Mikey, what does a woman represent
in Bible imagery?
>> God's people, his church.
is church. Very good. And the way to
confirm that so everybody knows that are
wa that is watching. We're not just
taking this concept out of thin air. The
Bible says just one example is in
Jeremiah 6:2. You can also read other
examples in Ephesians chapter 5. But
here it says, I have likened the
daughter of Zion to a commonly and
delicate woman. Woman, female, Zion, the
church. So he compared I have likened I
have compared the church to a woman.
Very interesting. So when you read in D,
I'm sorry, in Revelation chapter 17,
this is obviously a faithful woman.
Would you agree?
>> Yes.
>> But in Revelation 17, the Bible gives us
another woman. But is she faithful?
>> Nope. She's a harlot.
>> No. I want you to notice a brief
description about this woman. Go ahead
and read this next verse. Verses 3 and
4, Revelation 17. So he carried me away
in the spirit into the wilderness and I
saw a woman arrayed in purple and
scarlet color.
>> Okay, purple and scarlet color. That was
very interesting. Let's go back to the
attire to the attire of the Israelites.
This is the common priest's um um
regelia to the left and then you had the
high priest's regalia to the right,
midsection and the right. Now I want I'm
going to draw the comparison. Mikey,
look at the screen. I want you to see
the comparison. I want you to see it
here. Do you see the do you see a
comparison?
>> Yeah.
>> What do you see? What color is missing
here?
>> Uh, blue.
>> Very interesting. The color blue. So,
you have it begs to ask begs a person to
ask the question why. The Bible is going
to tell us. Now, remember this. The
Bible says that there was a a great
There was a not an
unfaithful woman. Okay? I didn't get
into all the specifics now, okay? But
the Bible does mention that. Now the
Bible says in numbers 15 37 and40 and it
reads as follows. And the Lord spake
unto Moses saying speak unto the
children of Israel and bid them that
they make may that they make them
fringes in the borders of their garments
throughout their generations that they
put upon the fringe of the borders of
their ribbon of what color?
>> Blue.
>> That's interesting. And why the Bible's
going to tell us and go ahead and read
this.
>> And it shall be unto you for a fringe
that ye make may look upon it and
remember all the commandments of the
Lord and do them and that ye seek not
after your own heart and your own eyes
after which ye used to go whoring. A
whoring. Yeah.
>> Wow.
>> So law by keeping the law will keep you
from going astray. Yes or no?
>> Yep.
>> That means that this woman is depicted
as a as an unfaithful woman
because she does away with the law. Does
that make sense?
>> Yep. The lawless one.
>> Remember this text? It said here, "And
his heart shall be against the holy
covenant." We identified it through the
word of God. It represented the law of
God. Am I right?
>> Yep.
>> So, the Bible tells us why. You notice
that priest you see the scarlet and and
and purple and scarlet there. The reason
why it is and the color blue is omitted
is because they do not hold to the law
of God,
>> right?
>> Not to the whole if you will. And
closing those verses, it says here that
ye may remember and do all my
commandments and be what again?
>> Holy.
>> Holy. You notice the word holy being
implied I mean being employed again?
>> Holy unto your God. So this tells us
that the law sin. Does that makes Does
that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Now, what is the biblical definition of
sin, Mikey? Do you know what's the
biblical definition of sin?
>> Transgression of the law.
>> Very good. 1 John 3:4, "Whosoever
committeth sin, transgression." That's
another word for breaking. Breakth also
the law. For sin is the breaking of the
law. So, if anybody ever asks anybody,
what's the biblical definition of sin?
There you have it. 1 John 3:4. Whoever
breaks the law commits sin. For sin is
the breaking of the law. Simple as that.
Now, for your listeners that don't think
but might be think, well, why they
always pushing the law? They believe the
law saves them. Does it? Does the law
save us?
>> No.
>> No, it does not save us. It actually
condemn us.
>> But who saves? Who saves us, Mikey?
>> Jesus Christ.
>> We don't want to lose focus on that. The
Bible says here, "Be therefore being
justified by faith, we have peace with
God through our Lord who
>> Jesus Christ."
>> And it goes on to say here, "For when we
were yet without strength, in due time
Christ died for the ungodly, much more
than being now justified by his blood,
we shall be saved from wrath through
him." Would you say amen?
>> Amen.
>> Okay. So this we got to understand it's
through Jesus Christ. We're not saved by
the law. We're condemned by the law. But
the law is perfect. It is helping us to
see who we are and was given to us by
God.
But we
are not his works either. How do I know?
Because in Titus chapter um 3:5, I love
this. Not by works of righteousness
which we have done, but according to his
mercy, he has what?
>> He saved us.
>> Saved us. And I love this other verse
here found in Ephesians chapter 2 vers 8
and N. Go ahead and read it.
For by grace are ye saved through faith
and not and that not of yourselves. It
is the gift of God, not of works, lest
any man should boast.
>> Lest any man should boast. So, we know
that we're not saved by the law. In
other words, I can't be saved by keeping
the law, but because I love Jesus, I
follow what he says. Remember, Jesus
says, "If you love me, what?
>> Keep my commandments."
>> My commandments. So, if so, the opposite
is true. If I don't love Jesus, might as
well forget it. Would you agree with
that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, now we're going to paper. So,
this is we're closing up with this issue
about paper Christianity during the
second phase or the more internal
problem that Christianity uh had to deal
with. It was a blow to them because they
had to deal with the insurrection of um
the reformers. Remember when they
started to grab hold of the Bible, it
was done in secret because they wanted
to know what God did say versus what the
priests were trying to tell them over
throughout the years,
>> right?
>> Okay.
The Bible goes [clears throat] on to
say, "And such as do wickedly against
the covenant, he corrupt by flatteries,
but the people do know their God shall
be strong and do exploits." Now, this is
this is phrase that is being employed
also dealing with Martin Luther. He was
wise. He started to teach the people.
But you know what? That king was not
going didn't really care about that
because we have here in Daniel 11 once
again verse 36. And the king shall do
according to his own will and shall
exalt himself and magnify himself above
every god and shall speak marvelous
things against the god of gods. We know
that we have a direct match to Daniel 7
25. But is interesting when you read
Daniel chapter 7 verse8 the Bible goes
on to say behold in this horn a mouth
speaking great things
>> and then if you go to 20 it says the
horn that had eyes I am and I'm out
speaking very great things and then
finally in verse 25 and he shall speak
great words against who?
>> The most high
>> who is the most high brother
>> Jesus Christ.
>> Jesus Christ. Now, let's just emphasize
on this point because that's I I I I
emphasized it on the last time, but for
those that are new to this channel,
probably watching this for the first
time and they're going to hear it here
probably for the first time. Says here,
"And the king
shall do according to his will and sh he
shall exalt himself and magnify
himself." Now, the terminology exalt, we
find it also in the new chapter, I mean,
I'm sorry, in the New Testament, forgive
me, that's what I meant, in the New
Testament where the apostle Paul is
actually writing of Daniel, right? He
has in mind Daniel 11:36.
Okay. Actually magnify himself as well
here. But in in um in 2 Thessalonians
chapter 2 3 and 4, he's writing to the
churchgoers. He said, "Let no man
deceive you by any means, for that day
shall not come," meaning the second
coming of Christ except there come a
fallen away first. Now he was predicting
what's actually happening today, the
decline of Christianity in the all right
and that the man of sin must be revealed
the son of predition. In other words,
Jesus isn't going to come until the man
of sin, whoever he is, which is also
included is considered the son of
predition,
he be revealed. In other words, that the
people will see. In other words, it's
going to be on mass. Well, who is it? is
none other than the leader, if you will,
the monarch of Rome, who opposethel,
I'm sorry, opposite and exaltth himself.
Did you catch that?
>> Yep.
>> Now, isn't that Do do we have Do we find
a match here?
>> Yep. Same terminology.
>> Same terminology here. So, we're not
losing traction. We're still in sync
with what the Bible says here. who
opposeth and exaltth himself above all
that is called God or that is worshiped
so that he as God siteth in the temple
of God showing himself that he is God.
>> We covered this in our previous session.
So I think we already I think this has
been nailed perfectly down to the
ground. Would you agree?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So now
let's go to the anchor point because now
we're going to shift to the latter part
because this is where I'm going to show
a lot of videos. It's going to get a lot
of people's attention.
Okay, but the anchor points that we
dealt with, remember we got to verse 22,
pagan Rome, we got to verse 39, paple
Rome.
But now we're going to get ready to deal
with the final phase. So what is the
third and final phase of papleled
Christianity, which is the king of the
north, this is what the Bible says. Now
pay attention closely, um, brother.
We're going to get ready to pray again
because this is going to be very
important and what I'm going to
emphasize on. M
>> Bible says here, "And at the time of the
end shall the king of the south push at
him, and the king of the north shall
come against him like a whirlwind with
chariots and with horsemen and with many
ships." We're going to get we're going
to dissect this verse. Okay. But before
we do, let's have another word of
prayer. Is that all right, Mikey?
>> Sounds good.
>> All right. Our beloved and kind father,
I thank you, Lord, that we were able to
grace through the first part of this um
book of Daniel. But now that we're going
to get into the more important part of
Daniel chapter 11. I pray Lord that you
would awaken the senses of every soul
that is out there.
>> Please continue to give us grace with
speech. I pray Lord that we will speak
kindly, lovingly to the people that are
listening. That you have our minds
intact, Father. That at the end of the
day you receive the glory. Thank you for
what you have unveiled to us thus far.
And I pray Lord that you will do it even
much greater with what we are going to
share with the people now. In Jesus name
we pray. Amen.
>> Amen. All right. So now
question brother Mikey are we now living
in a time of the end?
>> Oh yeah absolutely.
>> Okay the answer to that is yes. How
should one view the term time in the
end? Now this is where I've never went
to. Mikey this is very important
especially for those that believe that
it was the it was the issue about rather
that this verse verse 40 is dealing with
um atheism. Remember, you need to go
back to that study, okay? Part two, time
stamp 154. Look at it, watch it as an
entirety, then come back to this to this
um um third part and then try to see
what I'm trying to say out of this. Now,
when you look at that verse,
we have to ask the question,
in what year did we already establish
when the time of the end began? Remember
that from our last session? What year?
>> I don't know. We did establish that last
year. Last time.
>> Yeah. Yeah. The time of the end. We gave
a date. The time of the end.
>> 1798.
>> We're allowed.
>> Very good. 1798.
>> Okay. So now we establish that. Right.
Right.
>> So this is what I'm understanding. The
time of the end began.
>> But folks, everybody has to listen to
what I'm about to share with them. Let's
go to one other text to help us better
understand what would happen during this
prophetic time period. Okay. So, I went
to Daniel 11:40. But what I'm going to
do right now, brother, I'm going to go
to Daniel 12:4.
You see that phrase once again in Daniel
12:4. And it says here, "But thou, oh
Daniel," this is after the vision of
Daniel 11. This is closing it up, okay?
Mhm.
>> He says, "Angel Gabriel tells him,
Daniel, close up. I'm sorry. Shut up the
words and seal the book even to when
when does it say
>> the time of the end?"
>> What year was that?
>> 1798.
>> Now, I want you to read the following
verses. I mean, the following words. Go
ahead and read that. Go ahead and read
that.
>> Many shall run to and fro and knowledge
shall be increased.
>> Okay? So remember
in order to understand what Daniel 11:4
because the time of the end is the same
year. Yes or no?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. We have to understand this then
because this actually helps to simplify
what Daniel 11 time period is really
referring to.
>> Let's let's look at it again. So at the
time and the end which you and I will
agree with was 1798 or began in 1798.
The Bible then says this. Many shall run
to and fro and knowledge shall be what?
increased.
>> Okay. So now my question is what does
this clause mean? The all in red. Mikey,
I got a question to ask you. Now I want
you to read that again. Just read that
that remaining part of the verse once
again. Read it right there.
>> Uh many shall run to and fro and
knowledge shall be increased.
>> So I have a question to ask you. Did
knowledge increase immediately in 1798
or gradually throughout the years?
gradually.
>> That's the only honest answer can anyone
give.
>> Yeah.
>> Because did we come up with boats, gas
powered vehicles, trains, planes, and
automobiles all in 1798?
>> No.
>> No. Did it? How about the computer chip?
Did this happen in 1798?
>> Nope.
>> How about AI? Did this happen in 1798?
>> No.
>> No. But I'm going to tell you something.
I don't believe the verse is actually
talking about that. Let's go back to the
text again. Okay. But thou, oh Daniel,
shut up the words and seal the book even
to the time of the end. Many shall run
to and fro and knowledge shall increase.
I believe
that that's referring to the scriptures.
In other words, knowledge of the
scriptures,
>> right? I've heard.
>> Now, my question is again now, did we
gain better knowledge of of it
immediately or gradually throughout the
years? gradually throughout the years.
Yeah.
>> That's a common understanding that we
can we can only come to a conclusion to
or of. Am I right with that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So then let's look at it when we
see a parallel together. You see Daniel
11:40 which we know it began in 1798.
And we know in Daniel chapter 12, it
begins in 1798. But looking at verse 4
of Daniel chapter 12, we know that
though it began in 1798, eventually the
the what events were going to follow.
What's going to follow? Many will roam
to and fro and knowledge will be
increased.
>> Right?
>> Am I right with that?
>> Yeah.
>> So that same concept has to be applied
to Daniel 11:40.
>> There are people that are making the
mistake that are believing that in
Daniel 11:40, it's immediately and only
talking about 1798, what happened to
France. Remember what I what we talked
about before? That's not what this is
saying.
>> What it's simply saying is what Daniel
11 12:4 is saying. From that point on,
these events are going to be following
throughout the years. Does that make
sense now?
>> Yeah.
>> I'm trying to be very clear. So from the
year 1798 on 1798 onward until the end
of time, these events found in verses
4041 will follow. That's all it's trying
to tell us. But people want to lock it
in and say in 1798 this happened. They
are they're misreading what that text is
actually trying to say. And how do we
know? Just look at verse I mean chapter
12 verse4
>> and I want to clarify
>> you cannot sit there and say
>> yes
>> um just for anybody that is watching
this for the first time and haven't seen
what we're talking about they're going
to be like why are you saying the time
of the end started 1798 um Revelation
talks about that the beast which we know
is Rome had seven heads and it's on the
city of seven hills and all this stuff
there's everything points to Rome and it
suffered a fatal head wound and that
fatal head wound happened in 1798 when
General Berthier ripped the pope off his
throne and the pope died in exile. That
was when the beast suffered a fatal head
wound. So that would be uh a starting
point of the time of the end because
it's talking about it in Revelation as
this like future event, right? That the
beast would suffer a fatal head wound.
>> That's right. That's right. Remember
these events were going to follow. Okay.
Because it says that it received a
deadly blow and then it says and his
wound was healed. And then it says what?
All the world marveled after the beast,
right?
>> Wandered after the beast. So these were
events that we're supposed to be
following throughout the years. It
didn't just happen at one point
>> at all at one point. No, this happened
throughout the years.
>> And what Daniel chapter 11 is simply
doing is telling us the same thing. What
people tend to lock in that year time
again 1798. So this that's not what the
verse is saying. But again, for some of
us, it's hard to unwrap our minds around
that concept because we've already
wrapped it around and we locked
ourselves into it.
>> That's not how I understand verse um
verse um um 11:40.
>> But I don't [clears throat] want to go
too much on that tangent because there's
a lot of people that's not from our
church that will understand that
concept. Now, if you want to know people
that are just, you know, people that are
out there that don't leave the
denomination that we belong to or
whatever that we attend, I want you to
understand, you can Google it in 1798.
Even Google will tell you that the time
of the end began in 1798. They'll even
tell you we we uncovered that the last
time. Now, let's move forward. M is
paperled Christianity still alive and
well today.
>> Oh, yeah. It's the biggest denomination
on earth.
>> Okay. Remember, we were we're stemming
all of this from verse 40 onward. Okay.
At the time of the end shall the king of
the south push at him and the king of
the north shall come against him like a
whirlwind with chariots and with
horsemen with many ships. We're going to
get ready to get into all that as well.
So you agree it was yes. Now if in the
time people led Christianity is still
the king of the north who then at the
same time is the king of the south. I've
already uncovered this before but just
so that we can get more context let's
look at one more clue to determine who
this king of the south could be. In
Daniel chap 11 41-43, the Bible goes on
to say, "He, the king of the north,
shall enter also into the glorious
land." We're going to cover that in
detail today.
And many countries shall be overthrown,
but these shall escape out of his hand,
even Edom and Moab and the chief
children of Ammon, and sh and he shall
stretch forth his hand also upon the
countries, and the land of Egypt shall
not escape. But he shall have power over
the treasures of gold and of silver and
over all the precious things of Egypt
and the Libyans and the Ethiopians shall
be at his steps. So if I as I have asked
in the two previous sessions, I'm going
to repeat it again, especially for those
that are new. What do all these have in
common today? I mean, there's just
nothing else that you can ever think of
these places. Remember, he's looking at
a geographical location, looking at a
map. What do all these have in common
today? It is none other than Islam.
>> None other than Islam. Now, what we're
going to do, we're going to go a little
bit further now where I fit where I did
not do it in the two previous sessions.
I'm going to do it now. Let's talk first
about the Libya, Egypt, and Ethiopia.
We'll get to the Moab, Edom, and Ammon
in just a bit, okay? Because there are
proponents that want to say something
different. That's fine. Let's tackle
these first, okay? In Daniel 11:42 and
43, it goes on to say, "And he shall
stretch forth his hand also upon the
countries, and the land of Egypt shall
not escape." Now, folks, those that are
listening, we're talking about, I
believe, is leaning more towards our
time because Jesus is about to come. I
don't believe that all of these verses,
especially from verse 41, has been
its
peace escape.
Okay, what I said here was that
[clears throat] a moment ago that I do
not believe that this verse here has
been fulfilled yet. Okay, neither has
Daniel 11:40 has been fulfilled yet
either.
>> Okay, I believe it's about to be
fulfilled.
>> Okay, and I'm and I'm going to I'm going
to show you the reasons why in just a
bit. Okay, now it says here,
I mean, it's been it's been there's been
a great push over the years, but um hold
on. Let me get to this page. Okay. And
it goes on to say, "But he shall have
power over the treasures of gold and of
silver and over the precious things of
Egypt, and the Libyans and the
Ethiopians shall be at his steps." Now,
again, in order for Daniel to understand
this, he has to look at a map.
>> People tend to spiritualize this away.
How can you spiritualize it away and
turn away from the map and say, "Okay,
Mises, you was like, "Wait, hold up a
second. these locations that you can't
do that because remember north and south
north and south north is not is not out
of the way yet. It still will come back
to play again. Okay. Well, we'll get
there in just a bit.
>> Yeah. I'm not sure what a spiritual
north or a spiritual south would be.
>> That's the confusion, brother. That's
the confusion. Okay. That's the
confusion. Remember, Daniel's looking at
a map and then all of a sudden, no, now
it's spiritual in France or it's it's
France, but France is above Rome. M
>> that's more northern.
>> Wow.
>> Do you understand my point? How can that
be
>> the new the the south that cannot This
is what I'm saying. Looking at a map,
it's impossible. It's impossible. But
we're turning it to being become
spiritual now.
>> We'll cover that in another subject. I I
I'll even take care of that. Okay. But
let's for the sake of time and for the
sake of this um point that I'm trying to
to stress.
Ancient boundaries. You see there listed
Libya, Egypt, and Ethiopia. Do we have
those countries here today? We do.
>> Yeah.
>> Today, however, the borders are limited.
Now, you notice where now they have, you
know, closed in at. They're still there.
>> Now, I said the last time I said this is
predominantly Islamic nations. Now,
somebody may argue, well, yeah, Ernest,
Libya and Egypt, [clears throat]
they are. Now, remember, we're looking
at a map, but they'll argue and say,
well, Ernest, but Ethiopia is
predominantly um Christian Christian to
a certain degree. You're right. Let's
look at the at the statistics in
reddit.com. This is what it says here.
So, you see the highlighted portions.
You have the Orthodox in red. You have
the Protestant in blue. You have Islam.
>> You see it there where it says Islam.
Yeah.
>> You see the geographical
>> in Yes. The tainted I mean the color
that's in green.
>> That says a lot. Remember Daniel's
looking at a map again. A map. Even
though Ethiopia is more predominantly
Christian today, I'm going to show you
something, not my words. You can look it
up. If you were to look at the increase
or the growth of Islam today, check this
out. Look at the numbers here. Growth of
Islam since and it's moving. You can
tell on your screen it's moving. Growth
of Islam since 1985 in Ethiopia. You
notice you notice the years on the
bottom. You look at the top portion.
Look at that graph in green. You notice
that the numbers are skyrocketing?
>> Yeah.
>> By that year, those years right there,
you will reach that amount. So, it's
been growing and growing and growing and
growing and it's not stopping. It is not
stopping.
Okay. That's very interesting.
>> No.
>> Okay. My point that I'm trying to
establish is when you look at a map,
just looking at the map, even though the
Christians are more concentrated in a
certain area, but looking at the
geographical scale, Muslims mostly
populated. Does I don't know if I'm
making sense with that.
>> Yeah, it looks like uh Okay, so
Orthodox, I guess, is Christianity. Uh
Protestant is Christian. I don't know
what traditional means, but Islam, the
green looks like it it's
more than 50%.
>> Exactly. But remember, we're talking
about territorial rise. It might be more
um spaced out, if you will, but you
notice what it's saying. The greater
population, yes, is in those localities
of Christian. That's a clear. That's why
they say it's predominantly Christian.
But Daniel's looking at the map. So when
he looks at a 30foot angle, he says,
"No, I see more what? Islamic people
there." I don't know. I'm hoping that
I'm making sense of what I'm saying.
>> Yeah. Okay. This is now
>> new to me.
>> Okay. So now you have Libya, Egypt. We
cover that. Now let's deal with the next
three. Now this is the one that people
tend to ch I don't know why it's
challenged so much. Moab, Edom, and
Ammon.
This is what the Bible says here. But
these shall escape out of his hand, even
Edom and Moab and the chief children of
Ammon. Again, Mikey, I cannot overstress
this point. Daniel's not taking his eyes
off the map. He's keeping his eyes on
the map. The problem with some of us
today, we take our minds off the take
our eyes off the map and we're saying,
"No, it's this." Now, that's not what
Daniel's doing here.
>> Nowhere do you understand that because
the terminology of north is still
employed in the latter part of Daniel
chapter 11. and never says to to shift
it in any other way. But these shall
escape out of his hand, even Edom and
Moab and the chief children of Aaron. So
now looking at a map,
Daniel looking at his past
David when he came into when he took the
kingdom after King Saul had had died at
the ending of um 1st Samuel chapter 30
where now you have King David taking the
throne. You can read chapter 3, four,
and five. you find that he's now he has
a scepter in his hand. Now what did he
go about to conquering the surrounding
nations to give that death blow to all
these other challenges and by the way if
you study this the time of David he was
taking care of the remember the
Philistines was one of the thorns of the
um um of Israel's fle Israel's flesh the
Philistines for years book of judges and
onward right
>> David the vitic kingdom David he was the
one to go ahead and now just basically
decimate them
>> but I want you to notice the territory
that he had in his jurisdiction you You
have Ammon all the way to the up upper
right. You have Moab and then you have
Edom. Now these were the tribes back
then. Right now it's very interesting
when you look at the lineage of these
three Ammon and you have Moab. You think
about Lot and remember what you know the
immoral acts that he committed. Remember
all that right
>> in chapter 19. Okay. So that's where it
comes from. Edom. Where does it come
from? Well the Edomite obviously. Well
you have Esau the brother Jacob.
Remember Edom,
he takes off and who does he marry into?
The Israelites.
>> The Bible clearly states Genesis,
Israelites. Think about this. Now,
people have argued said, "Well, Ernest,
they have literally said this. I have
had pastors have tell me this, and God
bless their hearts." Okay, I know they
meant well, but they literally have told
me this. Okay, Ernest, Ammon, Moab, and
Edom does not exist today.
>> I said, "Are you sure about that?" I
said, 'Remember the problem is you're
taking your eyes off of the map. When
you look at the map, he's looking at
territory.
If you look at the map today,
territorial wise, if that's a word, what
do you see there?
>> Uh, which part?
>> The the the the brown part or the orange
part shaded?
>> I see uh
Ammon and Moab and Edom, Jordan.
>> Okay, so this is Jordan today.
>> Okay,
>> ancient Moab. Remember looking at the
map the jurisdiction
>> right
>> brother? Yeah, it doesn't matter the
name of it. Those names change.
>> They can change. But you know what?
Still, you know, Moab and and and Edom,
we can say, "Oh, they're not exist." I
know they blended away into society.
Remember what happened with the Mes and
the Persians. We have Mes and the
Persians, but who became the dominant
out of the two was the Persians,
>> right?
>> But you read in the book of Ezra, the
the Mes were there, but eventually they
disintegrated or basically with the
society of the Persians, they blended in
and become became eventually extinct.
But looking on a geographical map, you
notice that the territory is mostly
dominated today by what? Islam.
>> Because the country of Jordan is what?
Predominantly what? Muslim.
>> Yeah.
>> You have Aman, Jordan. That's actually
the capital. The capital is still there.
The the name still is intact.
>> Oh, wow.
>> But the jurisdiction is still there.
Does Am I making sense, brother Mike?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. This is what Daniel's actually
seeing. But some of us take off our our
take take our eyes off of the map. We're
looking anyways and that's why we can
make it mean anything else. That's not
what's happening here. Now for us to
understand about this three tribes, if
you will, what Daniel's looking in the
future, what he's what the Gabriel what
Gabriel's trying to help him, which I
believe this is what it means that he
this group shall escape out of his
hands, meaning out of the king of the
north hands. We're talking about Islamic
countries today. We know that they're
the opposers to Christianity for the for
for the most part, if you will. At least
that's what they're taught. I believe
that this clause is telling us one thing
and one thing only. The Bible says here,
"Other sheep I have which are not of
this fold. Them also must I bring, and
they shall hear my voice, and there
should be one fold, and one shepherd,
and I know them, and they do what?"
>> They uh hear my voice
>> and follow me at the end.
>> Oh, follow me. Yeah. And it read this
here. We read it earlier.
>> And this gospel of the kingdom shall be
preached in all the world for a witness
unto all nations and then shall the end
come.
>> Okay. So Mikey,
correct me if I'm wrong. Would that also
include Islamic countries?
>> Yep. All the world.
>> Right. I believe that this is referring
to some a group not the majority of them
that will accept Jesus
and be able to escape. As I mentioned in
in a previous meeting, I believe there's
a group because you can read it online
the stories that are coming out that
they are having actually visions and
dreams about Issa,
>> right?
>> About Jesus and there are they are
converting to Christianity. Look what's
happening in Iran itself.
>> Even today, people are literally willing
to die for Christ. It puts us to shame
if you ask me.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. And by the way, let me make it
very clear. I'm not against like I said
earlier, it's not about Catholics
against Catholics. I'm not against um
Muslim. This is not what this is about.
We're telling you about the great
controversy here on earth that the devil
has us so soaked in at that he wants to
destroy each he wants mankind to destroy
each other. But God is saying while all
this chaos is happening throughout the
world, God's people get stuck in the
middle.
>> That's all he's trying to tell us. In
Daniel 11 41 and 42, now we're going to
continue to move on. I want you to know
we already covered this somewhat prior,
but now I hammered further into it. Now,
we're going to go even further. But
these shall escape out of his hand, and
Moab, even Edom, Moab, and and and the
chief children of E Ammon, and shall
stretch forth his hand also upon the
countries of Egypt shall not escape, but
he shall have power over the treasures
of gold and silver. We're going to cover
that as well. And over all the precious
things of Egypt, Mike, when we get to
that section, you don't want you don't
want to miss that. And the liberties of
Ethiopian shall be at his steps. So now
when we're looking at these six
countries which I believe is referring
to Islamic countries are predominantly
Islam Islamic what I believe is
categorized in three groups. The first
which represents Egypt represents the
radicals the extremists of Islam and
joined by people Christianity. They're
the ones that just don't want that the
west is not going to tolerate if you
will. All right now this is a list of
some major global Islamic extremists.
Now you have the Islamic State of Iraq,
which we call ISIL or ISIS. That's just
one out of the many.
>> Yeah.
>> They always they have always been here.
They've been there before and they're
still here today and they're going to
continue to rise up later on. Or I'm
talking about the extreme. I'm not
limiting it to um ISIS. I'm talking
about any other these are extreme um
groups,
>> right?
>> Okay, that's what I'm referring to. So
there's a list of them here. I don't got
time to get into all them, but take a
picture if you want to. And that's what
it is. Now, let's move forward. The
second group, the second group
[clears throat]
is, excuse me, none other than the
Libyans and the Ethiopians. I believe
that they will submit. Remember when the
Bible says it will be at their at their
steps, I believe that this group, they
don't agree with paper Christianity or
the West, if you will, but they will do
it in order to survive. They will submit
to the terms in order to survive. In
other words, they're not going to hold
to the [clears throat] belief, but in
order to keep their lives, they're going
to submit. And the last group, Edom, and
Ammon, they're the ones that are going
to accept Jesus. It's not going to be
the majority of them, but it will be the
small amount. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, Micah, you see on your
screen, you have a map of the Islamic
world. I want you to notice that's the
map of the Islamic world today. And it's
predominantly to the south of Jerusalem.
>> Remember, well, let let me go to
Wikipedia. Let me share this with you.
The Islamic world. Now, I'm getting
their map. So, you know, I'm not making
this up. Nobody said, "No, Ernest, that
you you you fabricated that that that
map." I did.
>> How about this right here? What does
that look like to you?
>> Like Wikipedia map.
>> Uh population of the Muslims.
>> You see where it's highly concentrated
at? Right.
>> Yeah. Like I'm bad with geography.
That's uh Africa, like the upper part.
>> Africa, right?
>> Yes. Yeah. You got the Middle East and
everything like that.
>> But remember, Daniel's looking at a map.
That's all he's doing. He's looking at a
map. All right. So, Daniel 11 40-45. I
believe the king of the north still um
still continues to be peopleled
Christianity.
>> I'm staking my claim on that. If I'm
wrong, I'm wrong. But that's what I
believe.
>> That that makes like the most sense.
like you can't I don't if there's
another point of view I I'm curious what
they think that is but that sounds like
you can't not think it's paper wrong
>> you know interesting um Mike I didn't
want to really mention it today but I'll
go ahead and say it since you paused on
that there are people that actually
believe that it's Turkey
>> yeah I've heard Turkey I don't know how
the connection
>> now they they say this transition from
people Christianity to Turkey. Now this
is my question.
In Daniel chapter 2, the last power is
Rome.
>> Then Jesus comes. In Daniel chapter 7,
the last power is Rome. Then Jesus
comes. [snorts] In Daniel chapter 8, the
last power, earthly power is Rome. Then
Jesus comes.
>> In Daniel chapter 11, now it's not Rome
no more. It's then Jesus comes. Does
that make
>> sense?
>> No, it doesn't.
>> It doesn't make sense. So, you just
added another another entity to to what
the three already mentioned. Remember,
it repeats and enlarges the picture.
That's all that Daniel 2, Daniel 7,
Daniel, Daniel 11 does. It repeats the
program, repeats the the issues at hand
throughout history, but it gives more
detail.
>> That's all it's doing. But it's not
shift position.
>> These are the four that stay in power
throughout the years, at least on per on
prophecy that
>> Okay. But people believe that it's
Turkey. Okay. Now, I'll say this. If you
want to believe that it's Turkey, that's
fine with me. I don't hold to it. But
I'm not going to condemn you. I'm not
going to say you're lost because you
believe it. I know some people will say
that I'm lost because I believe this.
That's fine. That's how you want to feel
about me. That's fine. I still pray for
you. I don't believe that this is a
salvational issue,
>> right?
>> People will make but I don't. Okay. Now,
so does the Bible say that there will be
a third and final conflict between these
two opposing earthly forces? Yes, we
briefly mentioned it. The first meeting,
I'm going to go into it again this
meeting. Daniel 11:40. At the time of
the end, shall the king of the south
push or make war at him, and the king of
the north shall come against him like a
whirl. Now, Mikey, let me make sure that
I clarify again what I said earlier. I
believe that this verse is telling us
that something's about to happen. Mhm.
>> is about to you see the tensions rising
right now. Yes or no?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. That's what I believe that now
it's time for us to open. This is part
of the book of Daniel that God is also
revealing right before he comes.
>> Okay. Right before he comes, he's going
to unveil this. What could this push be
by um by the king of the south against
people Christianity possibly mean? Could
it be terrorism? I submit to you that's
what I believe. H
>> I'm going to play this next video are
radical Muslims I'm talking about. It
could be ISIS. It could be um um it
could be um um what was the other one?
Um the Taliban. It could be anyone.
Anyone. We're not limited to ISIS. We're
just talking about it could be anyone.
Radical Muslims wanted to conquer and
destroy Rome. Kingdom of the North
today. For those that did not watch it
last time, let me play it again. Not my
words. Yes, the CBN. But guess what? CBN
tells us that Catholic Church um tells
the Catholic Church changed the um the
law from Sunday to um from Saturday to
Sunday. I'm going to use that video to
prove the point. I'm doing it also here.
Okay.
>> The Islamic State has a plan to conquer
Rome. Yes, it sounds crazy, but ISIS
believes the conquest of Rome is central
to its mission and necessary to fulfill
what Islam teaches was the prophecy of
Muhammad and to prepare the return of
the Muslim Messiah, the Mai. Robert
Spencer is the author of the complete
infidel's guide to ISIS.
>> ISIS thinks that Rome is one of its
primary goals and that it is in its
timetable. It has a timetable wherein in
the next 10 years by the year 2025 it
hopes to bring about Armageddon the
final struggle between good and evil or
between the Muslims and the non-Muslims
and that uh of the chief stepping stones
to that Armageddon battle is the
conquest of Rome which they think
they're going to have they're going to
be able to do within the next five years
that is by 2020. Muslim scholars say
Muhammad prophesied that the two great
Roman cities would be conquered.
Constantinople and Rome. Constantinople
today is Istanbul, a Muslim city. Rome
remains to be conquered.
>> Once Rome is conquered in this view
within the next 5 years, and then Israel
will follow shortly after. They also
believe that during this time period,
they're going to conquer Saudi Arabia
and Iran. Now, before you laugh,
consider that phase one of the Islamic
State's plan to take Rome may already be
underway, flooding Europe with ISIS
fighters under the cover of the refugee
crisis.
>> They're not talking about doing it by
conventional armies. They're talking
about doing it by overwhelming these
lands with sympathizers from within and
an influx of other people from outside.
>> The Islamic State reveals part of its
plan in its publication, Black Flags
from Rome. It will use sleeper cells and
expects to get help from Muslims serving
in European armies and from non-Muslim
sympathizers. It also wants to fire
missiles into Italy that it is captured
on the battlefield.
>> This is notice that it wants to fire
missiles into Italy
>> into Italy. That's what they're saying
back then. Now, this is I believe in
2016, but it was projected in 2025.
notice that right
>> threat that is hard to be concerned
about and it is hard to see how ISIS
could conquer a city of 3 million people
in a nation of 60 million people but it
is not hard to see ISIS attempting it.
The conquest of Rome has been a primary
goal since the beginning of the Islamic
State.
>> They think that the conquest of Rome
will be the complete sign of Islam's
superiority over Christianity and defeat
of Christianity. They also see the fall
of Rome on an esqueological timeline
that will culminate in a battle near
Dhabi, Syria. Their version of
Armageddon. And they think that once
this battle takes place at Dhabi, this
final battle which they see coming in by
10 years from now in 2025 that the
Muslims will battle the non-Muslims in
this town in northern Syria and then
Jesus, the Muslim prophet and the Madi
will return to the earth and they will
together conquer and Islamize the world.
If their plan for Rome succeeds, ISIS
says it will throw homosexuals from the
top of the leaning tower of Pisa. But
the chief target is Vatican City in
Rome. And the main event as they see it
will be the beheading of the Pope in St.
Peter's Square broadcast and live
streamed to an international audience.
There was a convert to Islam recently
who has joined the Islamic State and he
said once we take Rome we're going to
carry out mass beheadings in St. Peter's
Square and so this is the plan to to
convert St. Peter Square into a huge
site of executions of people considered
to be the enemies of chief.
>> Well, my mic again my point that I'm
only bringing this to here. It's not
because I saw this and then I believed
it. I already believed that I just
stumbled upon this. No one gave me this.
I'm just searching and going through
things and I found this particular
video. I said, "That's very interesting.
It falls right in line to what I believe
the Bible's really saying. So, I'm just
using it as an example, but this is not
my go-to. I'm just helping people
sometimes they're better, they can
better understand it visually speaking
by by way of a video. That's the only
reason why I'm bringing this video. But
it's interesting that they're using this
and they're not using the Bible to prove
their point. They're not using the Bible
to prove their point. This is the
current events of our day. This is
literally the current events of our day.
>> So, I've shared this notice that the
main target is Rome. There is unfinished
business, brother Mikey. There's
unfinished business. Why? Because when
they look at the west, they see the
firepower from the west. But when in
terms of his spiritual leader, it's in
Rome. It's in Rome. Okay? It's in Rome.
Now, why else would radical is Muslims
desire to destroy Rome? I showed this
clip the last time. I'm going to repeat
it again. Listen to what they said. Now,
this comes I believe this one comes from
um from a a video um clip from Boris
Johnson and um it's called after Rome. I
believe this is the one here.
>> Yes.
>> Or one might mention the controversial
rallying cry delivered in the aftershock
of 9/11.
>> This crusade,
this war on terrorism,
uh is going to take a while. George Bush
says, "Let's have a crusade against
terror." [clears throat] How does that
sound to you?
>> What it indicates for us is like a war.
Bad people,
>> bad people,
>> bloodshed,
>> everything I think of.
>> Yeah.
>> But in in Britain, we talk about we're
going to have a crusade to stamp out
drunkenness.
>> Do you?
>> Yeah. We're going to have a crusade
against drugs. We're going to have a
crusade to make sure that people,
>> you know, don't talk on their mobile
phone whilst driving.
That's surprising because it really has
a very negative connotation here.
>> And you notice what she said, the word
crusade, it still rattles their cage.
Just that terminology,
>> okay? So, it's not forgotten.
>> Again, this is unfinished business. They
remember what the crusaders did to them.
>> And that's why when they hear that, you
heard what not my words, brother. It's
their it's when they hear that
terminology, something it's not it
doesn't fall well with them. Again, I
show I shared this clip. at least the
first time that we we um we started off
with our series. Hear what this guy has
to say. This professor has to say
>> Jerusalem is less than half a mile wide.
>> And this is a nar narrator. I think
David Keef. He's an actor, but this is
not who I'm referring to. But just a
moment, you'll see the professor
>> within her walls. The crusaders had
massacred an estimated 30,000 Muslims
and Jews.
>> News of the slaughter rocked the Islamic
world.
The Crusades
had a very deep impact on Arab society.
One, they were seen as a barbarian
incursion and stories of those crusades
are still told in cafes uh and in
families as if they happened yesterday.
This is something quite striking. And so
whenever the west has invaded that
region again, uh people say it's another
crusade. Which is why after the awful
events of 9/11, when the American
president inadvertently, one assumes,
said, "We now have to wage a crusade to
stop this," a shiver went down the
collective spine of the Islamic world.
Because they felt they knew what was
coming.
>> You see, that was back in his time. He's
saying that. And what do you think is
happening in the in the Middle East
today? M [clears throat]
>> you see how our present um
administration is talking already
>> right
>> it's better brother because right about
now just in just a moment from this
point on you have never seen anything
what I'm about to show you haven't seen
in the past okay
>> and it's going to relate bring us to our
country as well okay and you're going to
see the tiein to all this okay so now
let me get to [clears throat] the slide
here okay now are radical Muslims really
planning to attack Rome I think I just
said uh we're about from this point on
but watch this video and then I'm going
to move forward. Okay, this is the last
video cuz I think I shared this the last
time but after this video everything
from this point on for the most part
with the exception of two or three other
clip but I'm going to actually highlight
a little bit more on those. You're going
to see much more things that are a lot
more things that are new.
>> Tonight, Italian police say the
suspected al-Qaeda terrorists seen here
being rounded up in a series of raids
were part of a terror cell plotting
devastating attacks including suicide
bombings. possibly targeting the
Vatican.
>> Thousands upon thousands of people go
there every day on Sundays, even more
so. To walk in there with a suicide uh
bomb could cause catastrophe.
>> The arrests are part of what authorities
are calling an unprecedented terror
takedown across Italy involving al-Qaeda
operatives with ties to Osama bin Laden
security.
>> Prosecutors say the sleeper cell, which
included as many as 18 men, had specific
plans in place, but eventually scrapped
them. They had a suicide attacker ready
to go, ready to strike, and then they
pulled the plug. Why? The Italian
prosecutor actually says that they got
spooked because they knew that they were
being monitored by the police.
>> Police say they first began
investigating the group in 2005,
easedropping on communications through
wiretaps, but they never interrupted the
plot. They say the suicide bomber
eventually left the country, but the
cell remained. Tonight, investigators
say the alleged terrorists had an
abundance of weapons and plenty of cash,
but by 2012 had changed communication
tactics and the investigation had slowed
until today. Security at the Vatican has
been a major concern.
>> What I'll do is I'll pause it here. So,
I'm just establishing the point. You
see, they're even talking about sleeper
cells.
>> They're after Rome. They're after the
Vatican. They're trying to do it in one
way or another. They can do it as a
whole nation could like Iran would do
it, or they can do it just by alone a
lonesmen. It doesn't matter as long as
it is accomplished.
>> Yeah.
>> You follow what I'm saying?
>> Yeah. I want to ask something or share
something because
>> I I'll just be honest. It's not my
expertise.
Uh geography, wars, all that kind of
stuff. I I uh have better subjects that
I or other subjects that I'm better at.
But I looked up what's going on right
now. And I don't want to jump the gun if
you're going there, but um
>> Sure.
Like I know that America is teamed up
with Israel in a war against Iran and I
looked up is Iran a Islamic nation.
Google says yes it is a Islam nation. So
currently right now there is a war going
on with Islam and I thought wouldn't it
be crazy? This is just like hit me
because the book of Revelation says,
"Who can make war with the beast?"
Talking about Rome and they're saying,
"Who can make war with her?" So, what if
Islam tried to make war with the beast
and America says, "Well, you know, Trump
goes and sees the Pope and all that
stuff. We're supposed to be cool with
with the Pope and with the Vatican. So
it seems like we would go in and fight
right beside um you know Rome or Vatican
in this war.
>> You stole my thumb, brother.
>> Really? [laughter]
>> Okay.
>> Yes.
>> I'm about to plug them two together,
brother. Wow.
>> I'm about to plug them. You look
>> well I'm glad I'm glad I said it because
then it won't sound like I'm just you
know feeding off of your input and
you're brainwashing me or whatever you
know
>> for us Mikey that know look you when you
look at the Vatican they don't have the
firepower alone they don't have it
>> okay
>> but they have to have another system in
place to do it that's what I'm going to
tie all this into okay this is why I
believe we need to look at the verse and
at the time of the end shall the king of
the south push it meaning Islam and the
Islamic State, something's going to
happen. They're going to do something to
the Vatican or to the Pope itself. What?
I don't know. And it's going to cause a
massive a massive uproar.
>> And when it happens, you're going to see
that how we're going to I'm going to get
into that just a bit. Okay. But yeah,
you stole my thumb. Okay. [laughter]
Now, looking at the words because this
is this is where I left off. This is
where remember we got we still listen.
We're in verse 40. We still got to
finish it off. Okay. We got four more
five more verses. Okay.
What do chariots, horsemen, and ships
represent in our day? What does it
represent?
>> Travel
>> as it did back then.
>> Oh, war. Yeah.
>> It's a joint military conquest. That's
basically what it is. That's what you're
reading here.
>> Okay. But something's going to cause for
this military
for the for for these type of regimes to
go ahead and attack the south. Something
is going to happen. Okay. So then my
next follow now [clears throat] follow
me Mikey.
And what main
powerful military nation will Papleled
Christianity use to accomplish her
goals?
>> I'm I'm going to say America.
>> Okay. In order for somebody like you and
I to say or suggest America, we have to
understand is America in the Bible?
There are people that don't believe it.
>> Right.
>> Right. So let's see if that is true. For
those that have never had a study like
this, we have to go to the book of
Revelation. In the book of Revelation,
you go to chapter 13. There are there
are three beasts that are actually
mentioned. People think that there's
only two. No, there are actually three
beasts.
>> You got the first beast, second beast,
and then another beast that's actually
created, if you will. But let's deal
with the second beast here. The Bible
says here, "And I beheld another l
another beast coming up out of the
earth. And he had was like a lamb." Now
if anybody has ever done a study on what
beasts represent, you would have go to
the book of Daniel to identify to
understand to comprehend what a beast
represents in Bible prophecy. Now in
Daniel chapter 7, he has a vision. He
writes it down and he sees four terrible
beasts, land prey animals. And this is
what he says because one was like a lion
that had eagle's wings. The second was a
bear that had three ribs in the mouth of
it lifted itself on one side. You had
the third beast which was a
representation ree four heads remember
four generals Alexander the great
salucas talamy lysmicus and cassander
okay so and then you had the terrible
and dreadful beast that's a
representation of Rome faces of Rome
here now this is what the bible says I'm
not making this up go ahead and read
these two texts in verse 17 of Daniel he
tells us he identifies what a beast
represent go ahead
>> these grace these great beasts which are
four are four kings which shall shall
arise out of the earth.
>> Okay. And then read verse 23.
>> Thus he said the fourth beast shall be
the fourth kingdom upon earth.
>> So that means if there was a fourth that
means there must have been a third
kingdom. That means there must have been
a second kingdom. That must right. Am I
right with that?
>> Right. Yep.
>> Okay. So basically all this all Daniel
is trying to tell us is is that beast
simply represents kings, kingdoms or
political powers or empires. That's all
it's trying to say. Okay. political
powers. Okay? Now, remember, a king has
to rule a kingdom. However, when you
look at the second beast of D, I mean,
Revelation chapter 13, it says here it
has two horns like a what?
>> A lamb. Now, horns in Bible prophecy
also represents kings and kingdoms.
However,
if you ever did, we don't have the time
to develop the case here, but we already
developed the case in different studies.
Anybody wants to get with me, I can
teach you this. But this beast is none
other than a representation of what
country? What empire?
>> America. Okay. Now, I want you to know
the horns. It says like a what?
>> The lamb.
>> Horns like a what?
>> Give me what? Who? Who is the lamb? Who
Who does the lamb represent?
>> Christ.
>> That is the country that this is
representing
has some Christian virtue to it. In
other words, within its laws, the
concept of true Christianity is still
embedded in it.
>> This is a representation of America.
I don't have time to develop that today.
I'm just trying to bring in the concept
that America is mentioned,
>> right?
>> And we're going to get ready to we're
going to make we're going to glue the
two parties together, if you will.
>> In America, the Bible's telling us in
our near future again, the Bible, and
this is imminent. It's about to happen.
The Bible says in America that the beast
should both speak and cause. That means
to force. I want you to notice when the
Bible says cause, it means it's going to
mandate and going to force the masses
into subjection. That as many as would
not worship the image of the beast
should be what?
>> Killed.
>> So if this is a representation of
America, it's telling us that America is
going to force the masses. In other
words, it's going to force the
conscience. Yes or no?
>> Yes.
>> But hold up a second. I didn't know that
America would do that. Well, I didn't I
left it off. But in that last clause
here, it should be I I didn't I left it
off here purposely because I wanted to
get a different point, but because we're
on it, it says, "And he should speak
like a dragon."
>> Right?
>> And who's who's a none? None other than
who?
>> Satan.
>> Satan himself. But the Bible goes on to
say about America, "And he all exercises
all the power of the first beast." We'll
get to that in just a bit. for before
him and called it the earth and them
that dw which dwell therein to worship
the first beast whose deadly wound was
what?
>> Healed.
>> Did we talk about a deadly wound last
week or the last time we got together?
>> Okay, so let's ask the question. Who was
this first beast whose deadly wound was
healed? In Revelation chapter 13, the
first beast that shows up on the scene
is a beast that had seven heads, 10
horns. I want you to think about horns.
10 horns.
>> Okay. His feet has the feet of a bear,
mouth of a mouth of a lion. He has a
body of a leopard.
>> This is none other than a representation
of symbolic imagery by way of symbolic
imagery, a representation of the
Vatican.
>> Yeah.
>> Rome, Italy. So I want you to understand
the first beast that comes up is Rome.
It is the Roman Catholic Church. Now the
Bible told us that the Roman Catholic
Church was going to receive a what?
>> Deadly wound. a deadly wound. I saw one
of his heads was wounded to death. Now
Mikey, remember it received his deadly
wound in what year again?
>> 1798.
>> The year 1798.
Remember that? In the year 1798. We
covered this in our last week's or last
week's meeting.
>> Remember that. And if anybody that wants
to watch it again, you can go and watch
that program. This is the thumbnail that
you can find part two and dispelling the
deception of prophecy. We deal with
Revelation 11. We might even learn
something about Revelation 11. But in
the latter part, we also go into more
details about what happened and why I
say that it could not be atheism in
terms of um Revelation chap I'm sorry,
Daniel 11:4. Going back to Revelation
13.
[clears throat]
I don't know why I have these two
verses. I have a typo up there. And I
saw one of his heads that was wounded to
death. But then the Bible gives us the
next phase. And his deadly wound was
what?
>> Healed.
So you see the next phase. Now I want
you to notice how this ties into
America. Because if this horn, this two
horn, this um beast with lamblike horns
represents America, this is what the
Bible tells us. America saying unto them
that dwell on the earth that they should
make an image to the beast. That means
America is going to formulate something
that replicates Rome. The first beast
that is.
>> Yeah. that that image to the beast
should both speak and cause that again
force whatever this image is. We're
going to establish who the image is in
just a bit. It's going to force the
masses that as many as will now worship
the image of the beast should be killed.
So the image is a rep is a replica of
what Rome was before.
>> Right?
>> I'm going to get into that to establish
all that just to get I'm just going to
give you a little tidbit right now. And
if you don't according to what it says
here, America is going to do what? kill.
>> That sounds like America is going to
replicate what Rome did in the dark
ages. Yes or no?
>> Right. Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, does the Roman Catholic
Church have a strong influence in
presence in the United States?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Let's go back a couple of years.
Pope Francis 2015. Something that
happened that was unprecedented in all
all of the United States history. You go
to the US capital 2015 something took
place. The world has probably we have
forgotten but let me remind now Mikey I
stumbled upon this
>> and this was a
remember when Pope Francis came to to to
the capital
>> and he addressed the joint sessions of
Congress. Remember that?
>> Okay. Hear the word. I'm going to pause
and I'm going to have you I'm going to
emphasize I'm going to give commentary
to what the people are saying on ABC
[music] CBS.
This is a CBS News special report. Pope
Francis visit to America. I'm Charlie
Rose with Gail King in New York. Pope
Francis is about to make a historic
speech at the United States Capital. He
is the first pope ever to address a
joint meeting of Congress. Francis is
about to enter the House. It is packed,
as you see, with members of Congress,
senators, and other dignitaries. Tens of
thousands of people are outside the
capital watching on big TV screens right
now. Norah O'Donnell is on Capitol Hill.
Nora, good morning.
>> Good morning. And make no mistake,
>> now hear what
Sister Nora Oddonnell says. Mikey, pay
attention to what she's about to say.
Okay, listen. historic not only because
this is the post first pope ever to
address Congress but think about this he
will be on the tableau there flanked by
two Catholics uh the speaker of the
house John Boehner as well as the vice
president of the United States Joe Biden
almost a third of Congress is Catholic
>> did you hear that
>> almost a third of the Congress is
Catholic that was over 10 years ago
>> it's just gotten worse with Trump's
Okay, imagine what it is today.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. But but listen,
>> there are four justices of the Supreme
Court there, including three of the six
Catholics who currently sit on the nine
member court. So, you have an incredible
show of Catholic force in one of the
three major branches of government.
>> Mr. Speaker,
the Pope of the Holy Sea
Mikey,
our founding fathers of America will be
turning over in their grave if they saw
that today.
>> Right. I know, man.
>> This is where we've come to.
Now, am I suggesting that that person
there was a bad person? I'm not
suggesting that. I'm not suggesting any
Catholic person is a bad person. That's
not what I'm suggesting. I'm talking
about the institution that everybody
knew what it was about back then. It has
not changed. And this is where we have
lost sight. Remember, you forget your
past, you're doomed or deemed to repeat
it. That's right.
>> And we don't America does not know where
it's treading.
This is where we come in to warn the
world. Does that make sense?
>> Yep. I actually saw one time, I thought
it was this one, but it's either it was
either when he visited the US or the
United Nations or something, but they
actually said the Holy Father, and
everyone stood up and clapped. I was
like, I cannot believe they literally
called him the Holy Father.
>> I have a clip. There's a clip that you
can find on YouTube. All the American
presidents that are saying the Holy
Father, the Holy Father. All these, they
give a list of they're speaking it out
loud. the holy father. Well, he might be
their father, but he ain't mine.
>> Amen, brother.
>> Okay. Jesus said in Matthew 23:9, "And
call no man your father on earth, for
one is your father which is in heaven."
>> Amen.
>> Okay. So again, this is not to
disrespect anybody or any that's not my
intention. What I'm trying to say is
what does the Bible say and I hold to
what the word of God says.
>> Amen.
>> And this is where we have to come in to
show people what God says. I want to
follow what God's word is. And we got to
pray for people that disagree with what
how we believe.
>> Just pray for them. We don't hate them.
>> We want them saved as well. You know,
era has to be unveiled. Era has to be
you have to show the truth to it. But
remember, and you should set their they
will be set free by that truth. That's
what the Bible makes it very clear. Now
listen, let's look at the last part of
this. When he goes outside,
he addresses um the here.
[clears throat]
This is John Boehner. Remember after
this event, do you know John Boehner? He
resigned.
>> I don't know.
>> Very interesting.
>> That's the one the green that's the the
one in the he was the speaker of the
house.
>> Okay.
>> He was a republic.
>> Okay. He he was the one that got the
pope to come. After that, he resigned.
>> Interesting.
>> It's like almost saying like job
accomplished. Okay.
for invitation
to address in this joint session of
Congress
in the land of the free at the home of
faith.
Joe Biden, the speaker of the house, as
well as other leaders.
And now his holy father. Let's listen.
>> There it is.
Look at that scenery there.
>> Little sea of people.
>> Does Does it match the words that you
see or just about what you see up on the
top?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> And all the after the beast. See, I'm
glad you're saying this because I've had
people come at me when I say that I
think the the wound has been healed and
they're like, "Oh, that's a future event
or something."
>> I think it's been healed.
>> Okay. No, let me tell let me let me let
me I'm going say this, brother Mikey. I
understand why they say it. And the
reason why I used to believe that in a
way that say, "Well, it's healed because
like you look at a picture." But no,
>> in order for it to be healed, that means
it has to resume
>> its power and authority as he
And that is remember they also have the
power to annihilate people in order to
destroy.
>> Okay.
>> They don't have healing. It's gradually
>> exactly. Some people have said, "Oh,
they they got healed in 1929 when Bonito
Mussolini got with Gaspario. Remember
that?
>> And in 1929 was the big thing that oh
was he?" No, no, no. It was not healed
yet. It started the process. The process
already started. Okay? Everything became
gradual, my friend. Everything becomes
gradual. Okay? Now, let's move on.
Listen to this statement. Read the
statement here. Check this out.
>> The Roman Catholic is to wield his vote
for the purpose of securing Catholic
ascendancy in this country. Wow.
>> That's the objective.
>> World. Catholic world.
>> Okay. That's their objective.
>> Yeah,
>> brother. And I saw one of his heads was
wounded to death and his deadly wounds
healed. I'm tying the two together.
America. Okay. because you asked the
question. Okay, this is why we need to
go into the study to teach people that
America is mentioned in the Bible. Now,
I don't I'm not being exhaustive with
the point of establish who America is.
We can go to another study and I can I
can I can do that.
>> Yeah.
>> But for the point of today's subject, we
make sure we establish how is it that if
if the Crusades or the Crusaders were
able to wield this type of power and
this force, military might back then,
when we look at the Catholic Church,
they can't do that today. They can't.
>> Well, they can if they join forces with
who?
>> America.
>> United States of America.
>> Yeah, that's true.
>> Was the Catholic Church
a church and state institution?
>> Absolutely.
>> Okay. Check what this says. And he
meaning the United States of America
exercises all the power of the first
beast. That's the beast that America is
going to replicate.
>> Right.
>> Okay.
Is the religious power in America aiming
to control the civil government in the
United States?
>> Is the religious power aiming to control
the civil
>> church?
That's what we see right now with Trump
saying he wants to re reestablish the
country back to God and all.
>> I'm just tell you something, brother.
This is why I'm saying this was very
good that we held. We have to hold this
meeting today
>> to understand the inet to why paper
Christianity is going to annihilate a
lot of people at the end. In other
words, unfinished business and no one is
going to stand in this way.
>> Does that make sense what I'm saying?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Now, America, you've heard, I don't know
if you probably heard about this. This
happened, I think a couple years ago. I
think in 2022, Lauren Bober, the
American politician, she's, you know,
she's a representative for the state of
Colorado.
>> Headlines hit. Some of us know this as
watching this. We remember this back in
Yeah, it was in 22. Boowbert says that
she is tired of separation between
church and state. The church is supposed
to direct the government. That's what
she said. But just in case you think
this is fanciful, this is something that
never happened. That's the next clip.
Now, oh
>> listen, listen. And I want you because
you're gonna hear this here. What who
she uses as an example and hold to that
example, okay? And then we're going to
I'm going to I'm going to emphasize on
it later, but check this out. She's
speaking in the church right here.
>> Esther
had that revelation.
>> Who's the example?
>> Esther.
>> She said, "I won't silent. In fact, I
will go to the king which is against the
law. And if I perish, I perish. The
reason we had so many overreading
regulations in our nation is because the
church complied.
>> The church is supposed to direct the
government. The government is not
supposed to direct the church. That is
not how our founding fathers intended
it. And I'm tired of this separation of
church and state junk. It's not in the
Constitution. It was in a stinking
letter and it means nothing like what
they say it does.
>> Wow.
>> Now, brother,
>> that's scary. Do
>> you know there's some truth to what she
says? And a lot of people are saying
this is that now there are two extremes.
This is one extreme. Oh no, it was never
intended to be separated. Therefore,
it's supposed to be an established
Christian nation. The problem is they're
making it seem like it was a coercive.
They'll say no on one side of the mouth
and the other one they'll say on the
other side they say no, no, no, no. It
it's I mean, yes, it is. But then you
have the other extreme that say this was
never a Christian nation. Well, I beg
different. You know why? Because
remember that n remember the the the
second beast? It had two horns like a
what?
>> Lamb.
You never have that description ever
applied to any preceding beast. Ever.
Not to the lion, not to the bear, not to
the um three fourheaded um leopard. I
was going to say three headed the
fourheaded leopard nor to the devil and
dreadful beast. You notice that it's
only applied that terminology is only
applied to this beast. That's a
separation of powers within the um the
civil power and also within the um
church the church's power. In other
words, there's separation. There is no
coercive. There should not be no any
coarse between the two. Am I making
sense of what I'm saying?
>> Yeah.
>> But you notice how this this
congresswoman is talking, right? And
she's not the only one. I wish I I was
just I extracted this from other clips
from other presentations that I had. I
just said, let me just establish this
point. So when we look at the scripture
again, it says here, "Say to them that
dwell on the earth and look at the
arrows
>> that they should make an image to the
first beast." The first beast and my
emphasis that I added here italicized
that's my emphasis. The first beast is
the Roman Catholic people out of
America. They're going to make a
replication. They're going to replicate
it here in America. Well, in America,
they're going to replicate a church and
state institution. In other words, the
church is going to rule the state.
That's what Bobert is saying. She
doesn't realize what she's saying. And
by the way, there are people that like
to attack those politicians that are
talking that way. I don't attack them. I
pray for them. Yeah.
I pray because they don't know what
they're talking. This is what they've
been taught.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, this is where we come in. And
we got to do it out of love for them.
Not banging over their head and say,
"Oh, and no, we need to be praying for
these people." So, when we're done here,
we need to be praying for these
individuals. I'm going to expose more
individuals, but they're doing it. I
believe for the most part, they're doing
it in innocently.
>> Some may argue that,
>> let me tell you something. Let's just
say hypothetically that they're not
doing it um ignorantly. Let's say that
their purpose they knew know the truth
but they're doing it conscientiously.
Well, let's think about um Paul.
>> Paul believed and what he was doing was
right. Yes or no?
>> Right. Y
>> but did God convert him?
>> Y
I try to tell people everybody on the
face of the planet can still be
converted if they are touched by grace.
>> Amen.
>> But they have to make that choice. So
again, let me repeat. This is not an
attack to any individual. I pray for L.
I have prayed for Lauren Bolar just like
I pray for the president. I pray for
anybody and everybody whenever we're
talking about them. I tell the family to
do it. I tell the church and I tell um
the areas that I'm speaking at. Why?
Because I don't want to I don't want to
demonize these people. I won't like if
they do it with me
>> and I believe a lot of them are doing it
innocently. Does that am I making sense
with what I'm saying?
>> Definitely.
>> Okay. Now let's move forward. What is an
image? because that's what we need to
hammer in on. Okay. Now, in the Miriam
Western dictionary, the definition of
what a image is is a reproduction or
imitation of a form of a person or
thing, especially an imitation in solid
form. So, it's just a replica.
>> Right?
>> Now, remember the book Great
Controversy? We read that the last
remember in our last presentation,
>> we read quotes that. So because we
already introduced this writer in our
last segment, I thought it not being a
crime to speak on something that she did
write that you and I advocated for in
the with this book that she that that
she had wrote, The Great Controversy.
And anybody's watching, you want to get
a copy, contact Mikey, contact me. We'll
get it to your hands.
>> Yep.
>> For free.
>> I've already sent some out from the last
one. People um asked for
>> Look at that. Praise God. Amen.
>> Praise the Lord. Praise the Lord. Okay.
So, in great controversy 443, I want you
to read what this woman says.
>> So, it says, "The image to the beast,"
let me put this full screen. "The image
to the beast represents that form of
apostate Protestantism, which will be
developed when the Protestant churches
shall seek the aid of the civil power
for the enforcement of their dogmas.
Whenever the church has obtained secular
power, she has employed it to punish
dissent from her doctrines. Protestant
churches that have followed in the steps
of Rome by forming alliance with worldly
powers have manifested a similar desire
to restrict liberty of conscience.
>> Did you catch that? The image of the
beast represents an apostate Protestant.
Don't don't forget that.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. It it represents apostate
Protestantism. Then read the page right
before that. I did this purposely, but
page 442. Go ahead.
>> In order for the United States to form
an image of the beast, the religious
power must so control the civil
government that the authority of the
state will also be employed by the
church to accomplish her own ends.
>> Okay. Do you believe that?
>> Abs. Yeah, absolutely.
>> Okay. It's happening right now with this
whole um Christian nationalist movement
and all that.
>> Yes, it is. It's getting worse.
>> Yeah.
>> Now, I want you to notice years ago,
this is when I just started off.
Newsweek magazine printed this article.
This is the November 13, 2006. And what
do you see on the front cover?
>> The politics of Jesus. A cross wrapped
in American flag. That's Yeah. Pretty
bless. you hear today nationalism,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> But many of us just think that this just
happened all of a sudden. No, it's been
it was a grassroots movement.
>> True.
>> For years already.
>> Now look at the page when we turn it.
Look on the left hand side. What does it
say on the left hand side in bold?
>> Evangel evangelicals their long path to
political power. Wow.
>> That's what Newsweek magazine said in
2006, brother.
>> Wow. Yeah.
>> How about this one here? You turn the
page. What does it say on the top left
hand top?
>> Church meets state.
>> And they got all these figures that
brother this is back. I could give more.
I just I just extracted from my from my
other lectures just to get to establish
the point.
>> Yeah.
>> You notice what here now? I want you to
notice and he exercises all the power of
the first beast before him and causes
remember forces the earth. When it says
the earth that's everybody,
>> right?
>> And them that dwell therein to do what?
What does the dwell force them to do?
worship the first beast.
>> And who is the first beast?
>> Paple Rome.
>> Okay, I want you to understand
something, Mikey. That's what we're
about to start seeing even much more.
>> I'm going to digress just for a moment.
Remember when Lauren Boowbert herself,
remember I said she used she used an
example and what was the example that
she used? Remember
>> Esther?
>> What was the story that she used? She
used Esther, right? And she says about
how she stood firm and you know she was
using her example for whatever reason
her narrative.
>> Just recently we just celebrated Easter,
right?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. How are Christian evangelicals
viewing the issues in the Islamic
countries? This just happened this past
Sunday
>> at the White House. Trump invited his
religious speakers home. One of which
was Billy Graham's son, Franklin Graham.
He sets a prayer. Listen to his prayer
and listen to who he uses as an example.
>> Thank you.
[music]
>> Let us pray.
Father, you tell us
in the book of Esther
that the Persians, the Iranians
were wanting to kill every Jew,
woman, child, and do it all in one day.
>> Did you hear that?
>> Yeah. Esther again.
>> Esther, the Pers, because there were
Persians, which is what Iran, Iran, he's
he's right with that today. So, he's
using as an example. says they wanted to
obliterate, annihilate the Jews.
>> Well, what do you think is happening?
See that they're trying to merge the two
together.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. This is coming from Protestant
America. The supposed Protestant
America,
>> right?
>> But you raised up Esther
to save the Jewish people.
>> So, Bible raises up Esther. Remember,
such a time as this. Remember that?
>> Yeah.
>> Check the example now.
Father, we thank you
today.
The Iranians,
the wicked regime of the of this
government wants to kill every Jew and
destroy them with an atomic fire.
But you have raised up President Trump.
>> You've raised him up for such a [music]
time as this.
Father, we pray that you'll give him
victory.
>> Yes.
>> Father, we pray for our military that
you'd watch over, protect them.
>> Yes.
>> Father, we pray for the the people of
Iran who want freedom
>> to be set free from
>> listen
>> these Islamic lunatics.
>> Father, thank you for your son Jesus
Christ who came to this earth to take
our sins. That he died and shed his
blood on a cross for our sins. that he
was buried, he took our sins to the
grave, but you raised him to life. And
father, [music] we thank you and we
praise you and we give you the glory.
Father, protect President Trump.
>> We pray this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> So, brother,
>> you see who they're lifting up and
putting on a pedestal.
>> And everything is getting
>> it. Well, no, he's well, Israel. Yes.
But the person who who who are they
using into is equivalent to Esther here?
Yeah. And Trump. Yeah.
>> President Trump, right? So guess what?
He's the leader in the free world that's
going to be used, I believe, as the
puppet to accomplish the means.
>> Yeah, I see that, too.
>> And you don't believe me? Remember what
I played this clip what I'm about to
share with you the first time. Now it's
going to make sense. Check this out.
What did then presidential candidate
Donald Trump say in 2015 about what
radical Islam or ISIS, you know, he he
was pointing to ISIS really wants to
attack Rome? Remember this clip?
>> So, I just wrote this out very quickly
about the Pope. Do you want to hear it?
Should I read it to you? Okay.
He actually said that maybe I'm not a
good Christian or something. It's
unbelievable. Which is really not a nice
thing to say. So it's a response from
Donald Trump says if and when the
Vatican is attacked by ISIS you know
>> ISIS their primary trophy very few
people know this I read this about two
months ago nobody even believed it their
primary thing you've seen what they've
done all over the Middle East their
primary goal is to get to the Vatican
that would be their ultimate trophy they
want to do what they did to all of these
magnificent artifacts and all of the
beautiful museums that they've totally
destroyed all over the Middle East right
there. And I didn't know this. I read
this like four or five months ago. I
made mention of it two months ago and
everyone said, "What are you talking
about?" They thought like, "I'm kidding.
It's true." And now there are stories
about it. Not big stories, but there are
stories about it. And I was checked by
one of the reporters that said they
don't want to talk about the he called
up and apologized. The big thing they
want to get to the Vatican. Well, if and
when the Vatican is attacked by ISIS,
which as everyone knows is ISIS's
ultimate trophy, I can promise you that
the Pope would have only wished and
prayed that Donald Trump would have been
president because
>> So, does he know something? He knew
something. But I'm telling you, he's not
even using the Bible, Mike. Yeah.
>> My point that I'm trying to establish,
he got a man right now in office that
will do the bidding that he needs to do
whatever anybody places on his lap on
his desk
>> in order to do and take care of the
release anybody that wants to go
against. You hear how he's talking
today?
>> Oh yeah.
>> This is an American president. But you
know what? It gets even more
interesting. You know, it's interesting
that in this very same year, the United
States is celebrating their 250th 50th
annivers anniversary since their birth
as a nation. And this is how some are
celebrating it. Now, Mikey, what I'm
about to share with you, I just stumbled
upon. I wasn't even looking for this,
but it's very interesting just and this
is just a small clip, okay? Just a small
clip, but this is we're celebrating.
We're getting ready cuz July 4th is
coming up and you should see a lot of
the the the um Patriots. You see how
they're projecting it and how they're
talking. You hear their narrative.
>> Brother, when I saw this, I said,
"Brother," I said, "You can't get no
clearer than this. Check this out.
>> It's a song."
[music]
What? What? What rel What kind of
>> What kind of suit are they wearing?
>> Dude, that's the Catholic Crusades.
>> Isn't that interesting?
>> That's crazy.
>> Well, listen to the words, too. Listen
to the words.
[music]
>> 250 years ago, they signed their names,
put everything at risk for freedom.
Sacred flame.
They pledged their lives, their
[singing] fortunes, and their honor,
too.
Under God, they built a nation strong
and true. From 13 colonies, a beacon
rose to shine, a land wherew,
>> brother.
>> Dude, that's disturbing, man.
>> Isn't it something? But I don't know
what I'm talking about though.
>> Rome has his crusaders.
>> Yeah.
>> And they're about to march.
Now, folks, if I'm talking crazy, that
is perfectly fine with me.
But I think there's enough evidence to
say how we have it here today. We can
literally look at Daniel 11 literally.
You don't have to spiritualize it,
right?
>> I'm just trying to establish my point.
How has the Islamic world been viewing
the occupation of Israel in Jerusalem?
Now going, let me see if this is the
clip. Oh yeah, this is from that um
documentary after Rome with Boris
Johnson. It's another clip here
and um he's interviewing another guy and
he's giving you the reason not hear what
he has to say. It's a little bit choppy
because of his um accent, but just try
to make out what he's trying to say. Of
course, in the Islamist uh view of the
world after the conquests of Islam, the
Christian religion in alliance with
Judaism would constantly conspire and
again try to re you know uh reconquer
what uh what it lost. And this is why
now
>> sir reconquer what is lost.
>> Okay.
The bin Laden types, al-Qaeda for
example, don't speak of colonialism or
imperialism, western imperialism, they
shift the terminology to uh what they
call the newism, the Zionist movement,
it's colonization of Palestine and so on
as some kind of repeat of the crusaders
occupation of
>> You hear that? M
>> so by them now they look at it as the
west or Rome when you think about
crusaders it can only be Rome but though
they consider or they have grafted in
into their mentality the west meaning us
but you notice that he's saying
>> another crusade brother it has not left
the the minds of these people they see
what's coming
>> they see what's coming but it gets
better brother
>> Palestine and the inference is that just
as the crusaders at some point were
pushed by some kind of salah. This will
probably happen again at some
>> see they're telling you again this is
just their clip. Now let's see if
because again we got to understand all
this. Let's see if Daniel can give us
more clues to know what else people like
Christianity will do. Remember Daniel's
looking at a map and the Bible says here
and he shall enter also into the
glorious land and many countries shall
be overthrown. Some people say is
America, some people say it's something.
No, let's keep it exactly where it's
supposed to be at. At least this is what
I believe. Now,
has, listen to this question. Has the
world turned their eyes back to the lit
literal geographical location of Israel,
Jerusalem today?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> They have. Okay. So, now before we go
on, let me establish this that I
established this point that I
established in the first meeting. The
term glorious land is hit number Sean's
hit number 664. I'm 6645.
land in Daniel 11:16 and and 41:41 is
the same exact Hebrew word found in
Daniel 8:9. Like I said, Daniel 8 goes
hand in and of Daniel chapter 11, which
refers to Judea. And in Daniel 8:9, this
is a verse. And out of one of them came
forth a little horn. Think about the
horn. This is po pagan and papal Rome
combined. Which wax exceeding great
toward the south and toward the east and
toward the pleasant land. It's the same
strong hit number 6645. So you see the
word pleasant. It means the same thing
as glorious. So we know that that was
talking about Jerusalem. So why why does
it change here? It can't change because
we still have the geographical location
still here with us today. Yes or no?
>> Yep.
>> Yes. Now listen to this. Read this
portion. Check this one out.
>> And he shall plant the tabernacles of
his palace between the seas in the
glorious holy mountain.
What verse are we at now?
>> Uh 45 11:45.
>> That's the last verse of Daniel chapter
11.
>> I've established everything else. I'm
still going to I'm going to zigzag
within, you know, these verses. Granted,
because I'm establishing a point, but I
want you to notice because I'm
connecting what verse 41 said about the
glorious land, okay? And then I'm
connecting it to what um verse 45 says.
Okay? This one says the glorious holy
mountain.
Now, you're gonna have to ask a
question, Ernest. Can we prove from the
Bible where this glorious holy mountain
is located at? We sure can. All you got
to do is go to Daniel chapter 9. Where
did I say, Mikey?
>> Daniel chapter nine.
>> And remember, Daniel chapter 9 also goes
along with Daniel chapter 11 with verse
40 and 22 about the prince of the
covenant. Remember that?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. I want you to read what Daniel
chapter 9 has to say here. Read it.
Let thine anger and thy fury be turned
away from thy city Jerusalem. Thy holy
mountain. Holy mountain of my God.
>> So [clears throat] where's the holy
mountain at?
>> Jerusalem.
>> The Bible's telling us exactly the
location in Daniel. Daniel understood
looking at M. Yeah, I know that.
>> It would have been so confusing to him
if he said if if Gabriel said, "No, this
means something else spiritually." He
like, "What? You showing me a map? I
can't get."
And some people say, "I can't get it. I
don't see America on this map." I don't
get it. But we're spiritualizing either
way. Are you getting my point?
>> Yeah.
>> But unfortunately though, today, what do
you see in that picture? What's sitting
on the Temple Mount?
>> Uh that's the Dome of the Rock, right?
>> Now, just you know what the Bible does
next? When it tells us about the
glorious holy mountain, it tells us
exactly it location. Because some of us
gloss over this, but check this out.
Read this text, but now emphasize on the
highlighted words.
>> And he shall plant the tabernacles of
his palace between the seas in the
glorious holy mountain.
>> You can't make what I'm about to share
with you. You cannot make a mistake out
of this.
>> Check this one out. It says between the
what?
>> Uh between the holy between the seas.
>> Okay, so the glorious holy mountain,
where is it located? According to Daniel
chapter 9, where is it located at? in
Jerusalem.
>> Okay. Tell me if we haven't hit the nail
on the head here.
>> Wow. Yeah. Between the seas and
Jerusalem.
>> You have the Mediterranean Sea and you
have the Dead Sea. Literally between the
Jerusalem between the two.
>> That's true. You sure it's not a
spiritual sea though?
[laughter]
>> Okay.
Maybe because people say C represents
body represents um multitudes. Yeah.
Okay. But
>> that's not what Daniel that's not what
Daniel 11 is telling us. Daniel 11 keeps
it in literal for the whole chap chapter
rather for the whole setting of Daniel
chapter 11. We can prove it though.
>> We can prove it. Now there's other
chapters in Daniel chapter 7 or rather
Daniel Yeah. Daniel chapter 7 and other
chapters that you can understand that
this is symbolic imagery to something
else. But Daniel, remember, he's looking
at a map for him to understand this. Oh
yeah, that's Jerusalem. It's clear. The
Bible's making it so clear to us that we
cannot make mistakes. So, you know what
this is trying to tell us?
>> Something that the Vatican is it's it's
on their objective list.
>> Does paper Christianity really want
control over the Temple Mount in
Jerusalem?
>> Yeah, they do.
>> I think I shared this the first time.
What does it say? The US plan gives
Jerusalem holy sites to Vatican.
Wow.
>> How about this one here? Vatican presses
for control of what?
>> Mount Zion.
>> Interesting. Not my words, their words.
How about this one? Read that in the
bottom.
>> The Vatican wants the Temple Mount taken
from the Jews. Oo,
>> not my words. Who's really the culprit
behind it then?
>> Wow.
>> See, you Jews can do what you guys have
to do. fight, but in re the way it
sounds to me at the end, we're going to
take it.
>> They don't realize what they're doing.
They're you to me it sounds like they're
just pawns.
>> Yeah,
>> they use pawns. How about this one here?
The Vatican wants Jerusalem sites.
>> Now, this is back in 2011. And guess
what? You don't really hear it on the
news. I believe they're trying to
obscure it so people don't really see
the true agenda. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
Let's let's leave it to to to Israel.
Let let the fighting be with them and
let the focus be attention. But the
Bible told us and predicted something
else. Why? Because there's unfinished
business. Remember that is high real
estate, brother. That is high real
estate for them.
>> Yeah.
>> Interesting. 2014. Who are the two
figures that you see there?
>> Uh well, I see Pope Francis. The other
guy, not quite sure.
>> Benjamin Netanyahu.
>> Okay. Yeah. the mouthpiece for Israel
>> Israel president or whatever.
>> Yes, he's a he used to be prime
minister. Okay. Very interesting. So all
of this is happening, brother. So let me
take you back to 2023.
Remember on October 7, 2023,
this happened.
Israel caught off guard after the
largest and deadliest escalation of
violence in decades. Tonight, rockets
and air strikes continue to rain down on
Israel and Gaza after a day of shock,
death, and destruction.
Oh,
>> that's the Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu declaring
>> now
Mikey,
you think this is just happening just to
happen?
>> No.
>> Or do you think the hidden agenda behind
all of this?
>> Yeah. Uh um I don't believe any wars at
least now are organic. I think all this
stuff, you know, we got the United
Nations, all the leaders are in one
building and they're just coming
together plotting how are we going to do
this? How are we going to create a one
world order, the new world order and a
one world religion
is going to come about. And it's very
interesting a lot of these um Israelis,
they don't understand what they're
getting caught up into,
>> right?
>> Because at the end day, they're not
going to be holding the baton.
>> They're not. So, I have another question
to ask you. What could the main agenda
be? I mean, what could be the main
agenda behind this war? Well, you kind
of insinuated already to it, but I think
it's keep it in context to Daniel
chapter 11. I don't know if you ever
heard of Carrie P. John Bowler.
>> No,
>> she used to be um Miss California.
I think nearly I think it was like 16 20
years ago. Don't quote me on that, but
she ran in a pageant for Miss America.
She lost because she stated on camera
about her belief between um marriage
between a husband and a wife. She got
she lost the the crown as a result. But
she from that point on she stood for
what she believed in.
>> This is her today and this is where her
talking to Carl Tucker Carlson. Listen
to what they say. listen to what she
says because she was part of the
religious religious liberty committee or
commission in Washington what that um
that President Trump had literally
handpicked. Okay, so check this out.
The land means nothing anymore. Yes,
it's the Holy Land, but that's not some
biblical What are they going to What's
scary, Tucker, is these people like
Paula White and Ted Cruz and Dan
Patrick, they believe that there will be
the Dome of the Rock will be torn down
and they will rebuild that third temple.
They're saying it now. Look at Pete Hex.
There will be a rebuilding of this
temple.
>> I know.
>> It is heretical and it is
anti-Christian.
>> I I know that
>> because they're going to bring in the
animal sacrifices again. Listen.
>> And the most anti-semitic thing that
they believe is that twothirds of the
Jews are going to be slaughtered.
That's what these people believe.
They're just manipulating them and using
them. They don't really care. Isn't
>> that interesting?
>> They know something. And she said it's
anti-Christian. It's against the Bible.
That's what exactly what the Bible
They're on it. They're they're right.
They're right on it.
>> Yeah.
>> You can't slight them for that. But
what's the agenda behind it? And she
said Dan Patrick. She said, um, Paula
White brothers, she she got kicked. She
got booted out of that commission. I
hope you know that.
>> You should watch what happened. Let me
on. I think I showed this other this was
the clips that I tell you shared with
you. Could this be true be the true
sentiments with both the religious and
political world? Yes, it is. So, you had
Yseph Masra Richi leading Orthodox
Jewish outreach rabbi. He was quoted I
he was on camera saying the following.
>> If it was up to me the last time when
they shot hundreds of missiles, I would
print that one missile came from Iran
and shoot it down.
You know, [laughter]
then all the Arabs will go against Iran.
It will be the end of the problems. You
make them fight with other this bunch of
lunatics.
>> Never too late. You deal with a bunch of
cowards. Okay. This is his talk. Then of
course I shared this other clip with
you, Pastor Greg Lock. You've heard of
Greg Lock, right?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> Okay.
He He's a character, isn't he?
>> Yeah. I actually saw him live one time
at a debate.
>> Okay. So, you know, it's very
interesting. Again, we got to pray for
these people. We got to pray for them.
We got to pray for There's still souls
that still need to be saved.
>> Amen.
>> Now, listen. Here's what I think. I told
my wife this last night. This be the
most controversial thing I say, but I'll
be all right. I'll preach in a minute.
Somebody I hope get this message to
Benjamin Net and Yahoo
>> that he ought to take care of the rest
of them Yahoos.
>> Now, I'm going to tell you what would
fix it right now. By the way, it'd fix
it. It would help usher in what we're
wanting so bad.
>> Huh? while they're mowing down the Gaza
Strip
>> and letting them terrorists know exactly
what we do with terrorists, which is not
compromise or negotiate.
What they ought to do is evacuate up
there on the hill and get a great big
missile and blow that wicked [music]
dome of rock plum off of the spot where
it's standing right now so we can get
that third temple rebuilt AND USHER IN
THE COMING OF JESUS.
This is a leading pastor talking that
way.
>> Wow, man.
>> It doesn't stop there. You had the
president of Argentina, Javier Millie,
went to Israel a couple years ago.
Listen to what he says.
>> Argentina, they speak Spanish, but he
has a translator here. So, you'll hear
the translator.
There's a prophecy about the destruction
that says that a fox will break into the
holiest of holies.
There is another prophecy that says that
the same place will be rebuilt.
Now that I see with my own eyes the
first prophecy come true,
I laugh in joy and full of hope as the
second prophecy will surely come true.
>> So what is he saying, brother Mikey?
That dumb rock is is going to get ready
to be blown up. That's what it that's
what he's removed.
>> Brother, do you how do you think the
Muslim world is is is reacting is going
to react to this just by hearing talk
like this?
>> You understand why? remember that
>> that's the third sacred place in an
Islam in in in the Islamic world.
>> First is Mecca, then it's number two is
Medina, and then you have um the Dome of
the Rock because that's where they
believe that Muhammad um ascended up to
heaven.
>> Yeah.
>> Imagine it, brother. Do you see that the
world is ripe for another like World War
II, if you will?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, this is all that's taking
place on the news. Now, let me move
forward because it gets better, brother.
What are people saying is is Trump's
role in building the third temple?
Listen to Levan. I forget what my
>> It's an honor to be here with the first
Jewish president of the United States.
>> Set a date 300 years ago. He said this
will all happen. The Messiah will
arrive. The end times will begin. Now
they're looking at Donald Trump. One of
the rabbis illustrated how his name in
the gumatria, the numerology of his name
actually means Messiah and something
could happen overnight.
>> Imagine how big our president's head is
getting with all this.
>> Yeah.
>> And I believe that I I believe they're
purposely gassing him up.
>> Yeah. Oh, yeah. They've they've uh
>> they've called him Constantine. They put
him on a coin as Cyrus. They got a
golden image of him like uh
Nebuchadnezzar.
>> Okay, so they're doing this. So this is
why I believe he's the Nebuchadnezzar of
our day. That's I sincerely believe
that.
>> Okay, unless the Lord changes up. That's
just my belief up to right now.
>> Let's continue here. Listen to this
clip. Listen to this.
>> It lead to the reconstruction of the
temple.
>> Yes, he I believe is the Mashia of Edim.
See, and that's why I believe that the
gumati of Donald Trump is gamat
mashovit.
>> Somebody had to do it.
I am the chosen one. Somebody had to do
it. So
>> Mr. Trump could promise to use his
building skills to build a temple in
return for being the king of the Jews.
>> Oh my.
>> But what happens when modern politics
meets ancient prophecy?
Some people believe Donald Trump, the
45th president of the United States, is
like a modern-day King Cyrus from the
Bible or even a Messiah, suggesting he
was chosen by God to carry out biblical
prophecies.
>> And I have good reason to believe Donald
Trump was chosen to be the one to redeem
the sins of Asov through offering his
assistance in rebuilding the holy temple
on the Temple Mount and establishing the
Jewish kingdom over all of mankind in
Jerusalem.
Not my words, their
>> Wow.
>> We're about to Listen, if you ask me my
personal humble opinion, again, I don't
know because prophecy still has to be
fulfilled. We can only project. We can
only assume and we can try to point to
certain direction of where the
trajectory is heading,
but we don't know everything until it
happens. So, I I might not have all my
ducks in a row. And that's fine, Mikey.
Just like when you noted earlier, you
said something it may not be true.
That's fine. We have to try to make up
something to try it in, you know, fit
all the pieces. But if it doesn't, okay,
fine. No big deal. Let's move forward.
>> But you see what they're doing with
Donald Trump.
>> Could he be the one that as a lead
crusader?
>> Oh, yeah.
>> I'll let people decide that one.
>> But how about You've heard of Pete Hegs,
right?
>> The US Secretary of Defense.
>> Heard of him? Yeah.
>> Years ago, I think I I I played this
clip, but I'm going to go a little bit
further. several years ago. Okay, this
is back excuse me, [clears throat] this
is back in
>> and today Jennifer and I
>> He's in Israel
>> at the King David Hotel. He's speaking.
Okay,
>> it's 2018.
>> All right.
>> And today, Jennifer and I and other had
a chance to go see the Western Wall of
the Temple. Now, the Western Wall
tunnels, uh, so much of the old city.
And as you stand there, you can't help
but behold the miracle before you. And
it got me thinking about another miracle
that I hope all of you don't see too far
away because 1917 was a miracle. 1948
was a miracle. 1967 was a miracle. 2017
the declaration of Jerusalem as the
capital was a miracle. And there's no
reason why the miracle of the
reestablishment of the temple on the
Temple Mount is not possible.
I don't know how it would happen. You
don't know how it would happen. But I
know that it could happen.
That's all I know.
And a step in that process, a step in
every process is the recognition that
facts and activities on the ground truly
matter. That's why going
>> Okay. So, I guess there's a point that
you you hear you hear you hear the
narrative, right? Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, I don't know if you know this
or what I'm about to share with you, but
look at the picture that you're about to
see next.
>> Did you ever see that picture?
>> Oh, somebody just mentioned the tattoos.
Wow.
>> What is that tattoo that you see there?
>> That's a Catholic
>> crusader tattoo, right? Yeah.
Now, this became a big issue before he
was confirmed
>> right there paired up with the American
flag. Dude, like how prophetic is that?
>> Oh, brother, check this out.
>> Hours long grilling for arguably
President-elect Trump's most
controversial pick with heated questions
from Democrats.
>> The hearing also putting a focus on
allegations of controversial aspects of
his faith called out by protesters.
me members of his security.
>> Much of the outrage fueled by his
tattoos which include a symbol known as
the Jerusalem cross on his chest.
Another saying deis halt Latin for God
wills it and a common battlecry during
the crusades the religious wars led by
Catholics to convert Muslims a
millennium ago.
>> Did you hear that?
>> Interesting.
>> Yeah.
>> Not my words, their words. Though a US
military official told our Courtney QB
in November that those tattoos prevented
Hexath from being on the DC National
Guard security detail for President
Biden's 2021 inauguration out of an
abundance of com for the symbol's
alleged connections to those groups.
Hegath defended his tattoos to senators
saying he's been unfairly labeled as an
extremist. He did not mention the deis
vault tattoo but did note the Jerusalem
cross even appeared at the funeral of
President Jimmy Carter last week. Can
you elaborate just a little bit on what
what that what is this very offensive
extremist racist tattoo that you you
have?
>> Uh it's a tattoo I have right here,
Senator. It's called the Jerusalem
Cross.
>> It's a historic Christian symbol.
>> Pegs has openly embraced his evangelical
Christian faith as a core part of what
drives him. And to be clear, there is no
evidence he has any direct involvement
in any extremist groups. But he has
evoked the crusades in the past. His
2020 book America.
>> Listen, you see that book?
>> This is crazy.
>> Crusade to Stay Free includes a chapter
entitled Make the Crusade Great Again.
In it, he uses that phrase Deos Vault
falsely calling the wars defensive by
Catholics, writing, "Enjoy Western
civilization, freedom, equal justice
under the law. Thank a crusader."
Hexath's Nashville church is also part
of a group co-founded by Doug Wilson, a
conservative evangelical Idaho pastor
who has openly supported Christian
nationalism.
>> Hours long grilling for
>> Not my words, brother. That's
crazy, man.
>> I don't I don't know if everybody in
here understands prophecy the way we do.
And I that's why I wish we could kind of
go down that road. There is a video on
this channel under live. You have to
scroll down a ways. It It's probably a
year ago now, but it says uh what is the
mark of the beast or something like
that. It says
>> the mark of the beast is not a microchip
and it goes into
stop stop. No, don't don't do that.
>> Okay. I'm just point I'm just pointing
people to in that video it'll talk about
who who the beast is, America, all that
stuff.
But uh
[laughter]
>> dude, I'm just blown away because these
connections about America and Rome are
nuts. Do you know I didn't know this
till this year or last year that
Washington DC used to be called Rome?
>> And [snorts] we got Mary land like
Catholic Mary land.
>> Have you have you ever been I don't
know. Have you ever had the privilege of
being in in at in the capital? At the
capital?
>> Not at Well, no, not at the capital. I
don't know. I've been in DC, but I I
didn't see like the White House.
>> Okay, brother. If there's ever I I I
listen, I recommend people to make a
voyage out if they can and go to these
national monuments. Just get a piece.
This is American history. But go I've
had to this is why like I mentioned
every year and people that know me for
the month of June for the whole month of
June wherever am I speaking at unless
I'm asked to speak on something else I'm
always talking on Revelation chapter 13
in reference to America and I bring in
the history and I show things on the
walls plastered on the walls and I show
our history the good the bad and the
ugly.
>> I show it all. Okay. And it gets a sense
when people see th the um they get to
sit in for those presentations. They
love what they've I've had young people,
young children literally come to me,
brother, and said, "I love it." It was
this one young girl, my understanding
she probably didn't really care about
the church at all. When she saw that
presentation, the mother came and told
me, she was she's never been captivated
like that before. She has never seen her
captivated that way.
>> Wow.
>> Why? Because there's things in the Bible
that we can show. We got to show the
past and the present and the future.
Anyways, I'm saying you to pause for a
reason, brother. Okay. Now, but
unbeknown but unbeknown to the world, is
it possible that paperless Christianity
is the one who is covertly trying to
acquire the mount? And I already proved
that point. Okay, remember that little
headline. The Vatican wants Jerusalem.
Okay, now I got to ask you this
question. Um, because I'm going to get
to another point.
>> But will the the the question the real
golden question is, will the third
temple ever be rebuilt or built? What do
you think? Do I think it will actually
be rebuilt?
>> I don't I don't think it's like uh part
of prophecy really, but I think they're
trying. I don't know if it will be. I I
I'll say not without a war.
Okay. I will say this. I would have to
agree with you. I believe they would
try. I believe there will be attempts
and maybe it can get to the point that
they will demolish that temple of that
um do I rock. Maybe. I don't know. See,
this is something I want to be careful
on.
>> Yeah.
>> However, with that being said, let me
take you back nearly 2,000 years ago.
Just very briefly, you had Herod's
temple
in the latter time in the latter chap
the parts of the chapters of the
gospels, the four gospels, you have
Jesus speaking to his disciples.
Remember where he was quoted with saying
this from Luke 21:20. And when we shall
see Jerusalem compass and be circled and
circled around with armies, then know
that the desolation thereof is nigh.
Right. Right? And remember in Matthew
chapter 24, he's at the temple, the
magnificent walls, the building itself.
He says these words to his disciples,
"Verily I say, verily I say unto you,
there shall not be left here one stone
upon another, right?
>> That shall not be thrown down."
>> Now my question is this.
He's prophesying about the destruction
of the temple in Jerusalem. Yes or no?
>> Yes.
Okay. To me, now this is just my
personal opinion. If Jesus prophesied
that and for 2,000 years, brother, it
has been demolished. I doubt it very
much that he's going to allow it to be
re erected again.
>> Yeah.
>> Because it will make him a liar here. He
didn't know what he's talking about.
>> If anybody doesn't know, this was
fulfilled in 70 AD. Uh I can't remember
the guy, King of Ty or something. Titus.
>> General Titus.
>> Who was it?
>> You go to Rome Titus.
>> The arc of Titus there commemorating
what he what took place here in 70 AD.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. That day when they broke through
the gates,
the city floors, streets ran with blood.
The temple was demolished. Jesus
predicted it nearly 40 years prior. And
40 years later, the event literally took
place. Jesus literally told them in Luke
chapter 21:4, "And they shall fall by
the edge of the sword, and they should
be led away captive into all nations,
and Jerusalem should be trotten under
foot under I'm sorry, trotten of the
Gentiles until the times of the Gentiles
be fulfilled." Did that happen, Brother
Mikey?
>> I don't know.
>> It did. Yeah, cuz they were they were
destroyed down with the Gentiles. Yeah.
So, he um from my understanding, and
this is kind of extra biblical history,
but I've been told that Titus went in
there and slaughtered a a swine on the
altar, desecrated it, and and Jesus
said, "Not one stone will be left upon
another." And he commanded all his
armies to pick up every stone and scrape
the melted gold because the fires and
everything melted all the gold. scrape
the gold off and throw the bricks down.
So not one stone was left upon another.
That's the reason why
>> fulfilled
>> because of the gold that was
>> because of the gold that was embedded
in.
>> Yeah.
>> So he knew what he was talking about. So
again my brother in my personal opinion,
this is my humble opinion. Okay.
>> I don't believe that the temple will be
rebuilt because then it makes Jesus a
false prophet and the Jews can point to
Jesus as being a false prophet. Oh look,
he said that but look at us here.
>> Does that make sense?
>> Good point. Good point. Yeah.
>> Okay. Now, I want to try to finish this
off because it's going to get better.
Listen to what it says here in Daniel
11:43. I want you to read what it says
there.
>> But he shall have power over the
treasures of gold and of silver and over
all the precious things of Egypt and of
or the Libyans and the Ethiopians shall
be at his steps. He's looking at a map.
Remember this. And we're talking about
end times. Okay. What made this precious
thing that the king of the south had
that the king of the north actually
wants? Before we get there, just a
little bit of a history. Going to shock
you. This might even surprise some of
your ears here today. Let me give you
some history. I want you to read this.
This is Exodus 4 18 and 19. This is when
Moses leaves Egypt and goes into Midian.
Read that. And Moses went and returned
to Jethro, his father-in-law, and said
unto him, "Let me go, I pray thee, and
return unto my brethren which are in
Egypt, and see whether they be yet
alive." And Jethro said to Moses, "Go in
peace." And the Lord said unto Moses and
Midian, "Go return into Egypt, for all
the men are dead which sought thy life."
So remember he left and then in 40 years
he was going to return back. Remember
that. But I want you to notice that
Moses goes into where? What? What's the
name of the place that he's at? That
he's actually at
>> Oh, he's actually at um I don't know. I
said he's going to go into Midian,
right? Return to
>> Moses. Where? In where
>> is
>> highlighted?
>> Midian. Yeah,
>> in Midian. So he's not in Egypt.
>> Oh, gotcha.
He's a Midian.
That's my point that I want to stress on
right now because this is a little bit
of history that a lot of people don't
know. Midian. Okay. So, the question is
where is the actual Midian? Now, do
people do there are people that believe
that when they made their Exodus that
they went around and traveled in the
wilderness quote unquote in the Egyptian
peninsula?
>> Hold up a second, brother. I thought
that God said to come out of Egypt. Hm.
>> So, how is this the how can this be
true? How are they going to be wandering
in Egypt when he's pull them out of
Egypt? You get my point, right?
>> Yeah.
>> So, in order to understand where did
they go to,
where does the Bible say that the real
Mount Horeb or Mount Si was located at?
Because remember he said, "Come back and
meet me at this mountain." Paraphrasing
granted.
>> The answer to that is found in
Galatians. This is Paul writing. And I
want you to read the following.
>> Um, which things are an allegory for
these are the two covenants? The one
from the mount si which gar which
genderth
>> which genderth to bondage which is aar
for
>> oh yeah for this Hagar is mount si in
Arabia. Okay. Where's Where's Mount Si
according to the text?
>> In Arabia.
H
>> look at your map. And where's Arabia at?
>> What's it called today?
>> Saudi Arabia.
>> Ah,
>> Saudi Arabia. I'm building a case here.
Okay. I'm bringing this to stress a
point. Okay.
>> Now, I want you to read the next text.
This is in Deuteronomy. Listen to this
because remember, and I want let me go
back here because remember over here,
remember they wandered after remember
they were at Mount Si. Remember they
committed that sin against God by
building, you know, erecting that golden
calf. Remember that? And and and
remember that [clears throat] they were
at the banks of getting into Canaan and
right before they got into it,
>> they lacked the true faith and God had
them wander in the wilderness,
>> right?
>> Remember that story?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, I believe that they wandered
in the Arabian Peninsula. That's what I
believe. Okay. And I can set my my
reasons for that at another time.
However, with that being said,
just in case you think I'm talking I'm
talking crazy,
let's read this next verse.
And of Asher he said, "Let Asher be
blessed with children. Let him be accept
acceptable to his brethren, and let him
dip his foot in oil."
>> Dip his foot in what?
>> Oil.
>> That's interesting. This is an ancient
map, a 19th century map of Saudi Arabia.
I want you to notice the list of names
on the top. You see Midian, you see
Kora, you see Reuben, Jamin, Asher, Oed,
Israel, Aaron, Emran, Aaron, Joseph,
Moses. You see those names?
>> Mhm.
>> It is believed by names that ancient
names that are still there today that
that's where they wandered at
when they wandered for 40 years in the
wilderness.
>> Right.
>> Very interesting. It uses the word um um
Asher. Ash, one of the 12 tribes. Just
know.
>> Yes.
>> And he was going to dip his foot in
what?
>> Oil.
>> Isn't Saudi Arabia known for oil?
>> Mhm. Yeah.
>> You get my point?
>> Yeah.
>> I'm establishing my point. So now, let's
look at the map. The Islamic world. He's
looking at the map. He's looking at the
closing scenes. Let's look at the verse
again. But he shall have power over the
what?
the um the treasures of gold and silver
and over the precious things of Egypt
and the Libyans and the Ethiopians.
Yeah.
>> So precious things like oil,
>> I think it in order
in order to have worldly dominance
>> Yeah.
>> in the monetary um um realm, do you
think they have to have control of this?
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
Does the Bible say that the Vatican will
control all the riches of the world? In
>> Revelation, it seems to
>> in Revelation 17:4, talking about the
great and the woman was arrayed
in purple and scarlet, we talked about
that lady, the church color, and decked
with what?
>> Gold and precious
>> precious stones.
>> Precious stones and pearls. And then if
you go to Revelation 18:3, what does it
say there? And the merchants of her and
the merchants of the earth grew rich
from her excessive luxuries.
>> And what nation is the Vatican trying to
tie his hands with?
>> What nation of the world? Most
>> America.
>> The Bible says here, "And he America
causes all both small and great, rich
and poor, free and bond to receive a
mark in their forehead. I mean in their
right hand or in their foreheads." And
what does it say next? And that no man
might what? buy or sell.
>> So, in order to get this done, they're
going to use America in order to
accomplish this its agenda, don't you
think?
>> Yeah, definitely.
>> So, what may be the precious things
Daniel sees that the king maybe we don't
know that sees that the Daniel sees and
the king of the south may have
>> I believe is oil. The oil reserves.
>> It's very interesting when you look at
the countries with the most oil
reserves. Look at the list here. You
have [clears throat]
number five. Who's that? Who's that
country?
>> Iraq.
>> Are we Are we in at war with
>> How about this? Number four. What's the
next one?
>> Iran.
>> No, not Iraq. I'm sorry. I didn't mean
that. I didn't mean I meant I meant this
one here. Iran. We were in and we were
with Iraq, right?
>> Okay. All right. Three.
>> It's what?
>> Canada.
And we're not really dealing with them
right now. However, we go back to the
Middle East. What is that?
>> Saudi Arabia.
>> And then finally, how about this one?
>> Venezuela.
>> We already took care of that, didn't we?
>> H
wow.
>> Check this out.
>> Which country has the largest oil
reserves in the world? Many people
believe the USA holds this title, but is
this fact true or not? Let's explore and
find out. At number five, we have Iraq.
Iraq has about 145 billion barrels of
proven oil reserves and produces around
4.5 million barrels per day. At number
four is Iran. With about 155 billion
barrels of proven oil reserves as a key
OPEC member, Iron plays a significant
role in the oil market and continues to
export oil primarily to China. At number
three is Canada with about 170 billion
barrels of proven oil reserves. It
mainly extracts oil from its oil sands
in Alberta, producing around 5 million
barrels per day and exporting
approximately 3.5 million barrels daily.
At number two is Saudi Arabia with about
billion barrels of proven oil reserve.
At number one is Venezuela with the
largest proven oil reserves at about 300
billion barrel.
>> That covers it.
>> Wow.
>> And so this happens.
The United States hit Venezuela with a
largecale strike early and said its
president Nicholas Maduro had been
captured and flown out of the
>> Mikey. All I'm trying to establish in
order for the monetary system to crash
and for the system or the governing
powers to control it, mainly the Vatican
to become super the number one power, it
got to have a super world power in order
to be the new crusader, if you will, the
military might. in order to take care of
its business. Does that make sense?
>> Yeah.
>> We got to control it. And and remember,
we got to control those oil reserves in
order to become number one.
>> We we have to Okay. Now, could it be
Could it be I'm just possibly that in
order to launch a full-scale assault on
anyone that opposes the US, the US must
so control some of the black gold.
That's what they consider black gold,
>> right?
>> That is oil.
President Donald Trump says he wants US
oil companies to play a key role in
rebuilding Venezuela. The president
saying oil majors could be up and
running in the country in less than 18
months and the US government could
subsidize their efforts. Sources telling
us here
>> so he wants the oil. We already heard
about that. Now the question is does the
US want Iran's oil? What do you think?
>> Well, this is what it just happened.
>> 50,000 US troops now in the region.
President Trump setting his sights on
oil in Iran. Ian Panel joins us.
>> Trump is building pressure. The
militaries are on high alert. Is this
about Iran's oil?
The US president has not said it in so
many words, but there's one priority
that keeps that he keeps talking about
over and over again. He keeps talking
about how he remains laser focused on
keeping oil prices low. It is an Iranian
island that handles 90% of Iran's oil
exports. Seizing it would give the US
the ability to therefore severely
disrupt Iran's energy trade. That in
turn placing serious pressure on Thran's
economy.
>> The US president has suggested that he
is considering a move to seize Iran's
oil assets. He has even raised the pos
the financial times this that his
preference would be to take control of
Iran's oil. Trump compared the potential
move on Iran to Venezuela what they did
back in January where the US intends to
control the oil industry indefinitely
after its capture of former leader
Nicolas Baduro.
>> War with Iran. President Trump also now
appearing to want to escalate it further
over the weekend saying he'd quote take
the oil in Iran. Talking to Financial
Times saying he's considering taking Car
Island. 90% of Iran's oil passes through
this tiny piece of land in the northern
Arabian Gulf.
>> And who can forget his slogan, drill,
baby drill. It became Donald Trump's
rallying call to boost oil production.
Basically, he's obsessed with oil and
oil prices. And this is where Iran comes
into the picture. You see, Iran is one
of the world's biggest oil producers.
Despite Western sanctions, Iran supplies
about 2 million barrels of oil a day.
That's about 4% of the global demand.
That's what comes out of Iran. What if
the US gets access to this Iranian oil?
The American Oil Industry certainly
likes the idea. In fact, they're already
dropping hints. Consider what the
American Petroleum Institute has said.
This is America's main industry group
for oil. It represents the country's
biggest oil companies like Chevron,
Exxon Mobile, and Konico Phillips. Its
president is a man called Mike Smers.
When protests in Iran were at their
peak, Smers made a big statement. He
said, and I'm quoting, "Our oil industry
is committed to being a stabilizing
force in Iran if they decide to overturn
the regime."
Sus is basically encouraging the US
government to attack. It's like telling
Washington that if you invade, we've got
your back. We can handle Iran's oil.
>> Wow.
>> Isn't that interesting,
>> brother? We're about to close it out,
but I'm going to give you the bang that
you just noted earlier, but I'm telling
you how the Bible's predicted.
>> So, the Vatican is mo is is gaining
momentum, right? He thinks he has it
all. He has it all all in his hands. But
you know what the Bible says? The Bible
then says this, "But tidings out of the
east and out of the north, I want you to
notice out of the what direction again?"
>> North
>> shall trouble. Remember, he is the
established king right now.
>> Right.
>> But he hears something coming from what
direction?
>> The north.
>> And the what?
>> And the east.
>> Very good.
>> Yeah.
>> What are these titans from the east and
north that seems to trouble him? Let's
take care of the east first. I want you
to read it.
>> For as the lightning cometh out of the
east and shineth even into the west, so
shall also the coming of the son of man
be.
>> So what do you think he's troubled with,
brother Mike?
>> Oh, he he's troubled that Jesus Christ
is coming.
>> In other words, if he's the king, does
do they want another rival king taking
their position?
>> Nope.
>> No. You see what the Bible's saying here
then? But tidings out of the This is
news. This is news out of these. In
other words, there are messages that are
being relayed that another is coming.
Did you get it?
>> Yeah.
>> Get it? Now, what is that real message?
I want you to read Revelation 18.
>> And I saw another angel come down from
heaven having a great power and the
earth was lightened with his glory. And
he cried mightily with a strong voice,
saying, Babylon the great is fallen as
fallen.
>> Continue.
>> And I heard another voice from heaven,
saying, Come out of her, my people, that
ye may not be part that ye be not
partakers of her sins, and that ye
receive not of her plagues. For her sins
have reached unto heaven, and God hath
remembered her iniquities.
>> Don't you think that's the news that
troubles her? Oh yeah,
>> it does. Right. And why? Because of what
the third angel's message of Revelation
14 says. You have one, two, and then
three. I want you to go ahead and read
this third angel's message. Go ahead.
Verses 9 through11.
>> And the third angel followed them,
saying with a loud voice, "If any man
worship the beast and his image, and
receive his mark in his forehead or in
his hand."
I'm sorry. Sorry. Go ahead. Read this
one right here.
>> And the same shall drink of the wine of
the wrath of God, which is poured out
without mixture into the cup of his
indignation. And he shall be tormented
with fire and brimstone in the presence
of the holy angels and in the presence
of the lamb.
>> Thank you.
>> And the smoke of their torment ascendeth
up forever and ever. And they have no
rest day nor night who worship the beast
and his image. And whoever receiveth the
mark of his name.
>> Weren't you talking about a mark
earlier?
>> Yep.
>> Okay. There's news that's troubling it.
It's about the second coming of Christ.
>> He's coming from the east. Remember, as
the east rather rather the Bible says,
so as the lightning cometh out of the
east and shineth unto the so shall it
also the coming of the son of man be.
That's very interesting. We're gluing
we're gluing the scriptures together.
But remember, it's always the new rising
king that comes from what direction?
>> The east.
>> No, no, no, no, no. In all of Daniel,
the north king.
>> Yeah. The north.
>> That's north. Very good.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> That's north. That's from the heavens.
Yes or no.
>> Yeah.
You know the revelation 5 112 says and I
heard the voice of angel many angels
saying with a loud voice worthy is the
lamb that was slain to p to receive
power and riches and wisdom and strength
and honor and glory. And remember in
revelation 19:15 and 16 it says he shall
rule and on his thigh a name written
what does it say there?
>> King of kings.
>> Do you know what's happening? He's
troubled about the second coming of
Christ.
>> Yeah. And also the messages that are
coming. Repent. Repent Babylon. Remember
the church on mystery name written on a
foreign mystery. Babylon the mother of
harlots. Remember that.
>> So the message is against institution
and it's calling the people out of that
institution to grab hold of Christ
because he's about to come.
>> But it talked about that mark. Remember
that.
>> Yeah.
>> The second beast in Revelation 13. You
you're gonna be surprised on what you're
gonna see here. Okay. Revelation what
what the Bible says here. Okay. The
Bible says here
in Revelation [clears throat] 13:16 that
he calls us all, both small and great,
rich and poor, free and bond to receive
a what, Mikey?
>> A mark.
>> Okay. Now, I want you to notice in their
right hand or in their where?
>> Foreheads.
>> Now, Mikey, your listeners need to pay
close attention to this and they might
have to review it over and over and over
to get it. In order to know what the
mark of peace is, we need to know and
understand what the healing sign and
seal of God is. In other words, what I'm
saying here, if anybody wants to
understand what the mark of the beast
is, they have to first find out what the
sign or seal of God is. Does that make
sense?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So now I want I'm going to give it
to you. Look at your screen. In the New
Testament, the word mark, Strong's hit
number 5480, basically means you can
read it up. You don't take my words for
it. an imprinted mark. That's what it
means.
>> Yeah.
>> But it's interesting when you see the
word seal,
>> Strong's hit number 40 4873. What does
it what's the meaning of the word seal?
>> It's a mark as well.
>> So that means the seal actually means a
mark. Right.
>> Right.
>> Yep.
>> That means God has a mark and the devil
has a mark.
>> That's right.
>> But the only difference is it's
transliterated for God's is the seal.
Now in the Old Testament, you have the
word sign which actually means a what?
mark as well.
>> So the word seal and sign is actually a
mark, but those seal those words seal
and sign is referring to the mark of
God,
>> right?
>> So God has a mark and the beast has a
mark. Does that make sense?
>> Yep. There's a counterfeit.
>> Okay. Check. Yeah. Very good. Check this
out. So I'm going to take you back to
the story of Moses. Remember Moses
receives the law of God. And I want you
to read Read this text. Read this text.
And he gave unto Moses, when he had made
an end of communing with him upon Mount
Si, two tables of testimony, tables of
stone written with the finger of God.
Okay? Now, I want you to notice how I'm
laying this out. In Exodus 31:13, I want
you to notice it says here, "Speak thou
also unto the children of Israel,
saying, "Verily, my Sabbath shall ye
keep, for it shall be a what, Mikey?"
>> A sign or a mark. a word. Very good. You
caught on to a mark between me and you
throughout your generations that ye may
know that I am the Lord that does
sanctify. So what I'm trying to
establish here, God has a mark and the
Bible is telling us what is his mark. It
is the Sabbath. Yes or no?
>> Yep.
>> So this is good mark. This is the good
seal if you will. This is the sign of
God.
>> Now let's go to Ezekiel chapter 20 verse
12. What does it say here? Moreover also
I gave them my Sabbaths to be a sign or
a mark between me and them that they may
know that I am the Lord that sanctify
them.
>> Very good. Now let's go back to this
text because the mark is put is placed
where?
>> Um in the forehead or in the hand.
>> I want you to notice or it doesn't say
and
>> no. Yeah.
>> Okay. So there's a difference
intellectually in the mind and in the
hand voluntarily. In other words, they
don't have to intellectually accept it,
right?
>> But they're going to do it because of
course if they don't, they're not going
to be able to buy or sell. You get my
point, right?
>> Right.
>> Now, no, I want you to notice I know
notice the difference of the mark and
how it's placed and how God's seal or
sign is placed. Let's go to Deuteronomy
6:es 1 5-8. Go ahead and read it.
>> These are the commandments. And thou
shalt love the Lord thy God with all
thine heart, with all thy soul, with all
thy might, and these words which I
command thee this day shall be in thine
heart.
>> Now lead continue to read.
>> And thou shalt teach them diligently
unto thy children, and shall talk of
them when thou sitest in thine house,
and when thou walst by the way, and when
thy thou liest down.
>> Oops. And when thou riseth up,
>> and thou shalt bind them for a sign or a
mark upon thine hand, and they shall be
as frontlets between thy eyes, forehead.
>> You notice the word there. What does the
word sign also mean?
>> Mark.
>> Mark. And what is it in Mark? According
to this text, what is this mark?
>> The commandments.
>> The commandments. And where are they
placed at? and the hand and between the
eyes and the forehead
>> because God's people intellectually
accepts the law of God in its fullness
and they applied in their lives as well.
In other words, their works follow what
they believe.
>> Amen.
>> They don't have a choice to say, "Okay,
I'm just going to do it, but I don't
really not God's people,
>> right?
>> Whereas East has a market. It doesn't
matter where we place it at. If you
believe it, you're believing the lie.
But if you don't believe it because you
want to pay your bills, you're going to
have to accept it. Does that make sense?
>> That's right. Yeah.
>> Now, read Exodus 13 verse 9 and 16.
Well, I actually gave you only one
verse, but go ahead.
>> And it shall be for a sign or mark under
thee upon thine hand, and for a memorial
between thine eyes, that the Lord's law
may be in thy mouth.
>> You notice that?
>> Yep. That's the Lord's law.
So, in other words, if the Bible's
telling us that the seal and and and
sign of God is a mark, but it's the
commandments and specifically the
Sabbath, the question is, what does the
Roman Catholic Church say the mark is?
>> Well, let me give you some quotations.
According to the Catholic record of
London, Ontario, and Canada dated
September 1st, 1923, Sunday is our mark
of authority. The church is above the
Bible and the transference, that's
another word for changing of Sabbath
observance is proof of that fact. Wow.
>> End the quote.
>> Their words, not my words. Now, does the
Roman Catholic Church further admit to
the changing of the seventh day Sabbath
to the Sunday as a as her mark of
authority? Yes. Because this influential
character at his time, James Cardinal
Given, he was the archbishop of
Baltimore, was quoted with saying the
following. Go ahead and read it. Of
course, the Catholic Church claims that
the change was her act and the act is a
mark of her ecclesiastical power and
authority in religious matters.
>> Not my words, his words.
>> That's right.
>> So then quite we found the opposite. We
already know what the mark of the beast
is. We have to because it is Sunday
observance.
>> Yeah. Forced Sunday observance.
>> Exactly. Exactly. But now let's go back
to the map.
Jews s called what day?
>> They uh Jews.
>> Oh, let me take it back. Daniel held
what day? Sacred?
>> Sabbath. Sun. Uh Saturday, seventh day.
>> So, let's look at the map. Let's look at
the map. Okay. So, Christianity to the
north. So, holds what day?
>> Sunday.
>> And Islam to the south holds what day?
Friday.
>> Don't get stuck in the middle again.
God's people,
>> Jerusalem. Yeah. Spiritual Israel.
>> Get it?
>> Yeah.
>> You get it? So, there's going to be a
con a contest between God's law, his
Sabbath, and the mark of the beast the
Sunday.
>> God's people are proclaiming this with
those angels that are f, you know, seen
flying in the midst of heaven in
Revelation 14. God's people are going to
be calling the world to return back to
honoring God in the full ten
commandments of his law. Not nine of
them, not eight of them.
>> Right?
>> Okay. This is what's troubling the Roman
Catholic leadership because they hear
about another that is coming. And I'm
going to tell you something because it's
bothering them, bothering the
institution. As a result, what will the
king of the north seek to do? The Bible
tells us, listen to what it says in
Daniel 11:44. Therefore, he the king of
the north shall go forth with great fury
to destroy and utterly to make away
many. Did you get it?
>> Wow. Yeah.
>> What's going to happen? If you look at
the picture, you see that little horn on
the top. It's going to use the
>> is going to use the military might of
the world. And let me tell you
something, Mikey. A lot of us are going
to be arraigned in courts.
We're going to have to testify on what
we believe.
>> Yeah.
>> Some of us are going to be locked up
because of what we believe. And some of
us are going to use that stand to share
to the world the truth of God's word in
these last days. Would you agree?
>> Amen. [snorts] It's going to be like the
uh Roman coliseums.
>> Exactly. And much worse. Remember what
happened back then is nothing compared
to what's going to happen now.
>> Right.
>> I know. I'll share with you in just a
Could this earthly nor king of the north
be troubled because he hears messages
and news about another mightier king
that's approaching from the north?
>> I want you to think about it. M
>> north up north when you look up other no
that's a rival now
>> okay
>> but who does Daniel say would rescue the
people from this earthly king of the
north
>> this is what it says here and at that
time shall Michael stand up the great
prince which standeth for the children
of thy people and at that time thy
people remember he's speaking of Daniel
shall be delivered everyone that should
be found written in the book
>> so the question is who is this Michael
the prince well guess We've already
exhausted today's lecture. So, this is
where we'll end it.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> All right. I'll let your followers or
your viewers go ahead and search that
one out on their own. Okay.
>> Amen.
>> But I think we established our point
here tonight,
Brother Mikey. Okay. That's what I
believe.
>> That That was good, man. I'm You know,
I'm still like open just like you are.
We're both truth seeking, open to ideas.
We want to hear your ideas. Tell us in
the comments. We want to read this
stuff. Ernest says, "Call him up. We're
going to put his phone number in the
description."
>> No problem doing it. I have no problem
hearing what you,
>> you know, I've been hearing some of the
other side. And there are some points
that that make sense to me like um for
so the atheism thing.
Well, it's like there's going to be like
basically religion versus no religion or
something. But but you've shown me some
things today that really kind of
solidify the point that you're making
that I'm predicting and I'm not a
prophet, but it does seem like
they're talking about taking over that
Dome of the Rock, building that third
temple. they keep talking about it and
if they try to do that there's going to
be war with Islam
and if if uh Islam's main mission is to
fight against Rome and we know that
that's the beast that's handinhand with
the second beast America
there's going to be a war you know who
can make war with the beast who can make
war with Rome and and America is going
to be siding with them so if there's a
war because of this Dome of the Rock
thing this third simple thing. It's
going to be with Islam.
>> Yeah. And that's the whole thing. We
don't know how events are really going
to unfold. We can just get some clues
and a picture, a window to what's going
to happen. So, you know, take what I say
with a grain of salt to a certain
extent. You get what I'm saying? Like,
you know,
>> only because it has not been fulfilled
yet. So, I don't want to act like, oh,
this is exactly going to happen in this
order. But from my studying, brother
Mikey, this is the conclusion that I
come to. Now believe since we're living
in the last days is it's going to reveal
the light. Now again I I repeat and I
started off with this notion. I'm going
to close it with this notion. If I am
wrong humbly loving I say it's fine,
>> right?
>> It's fine. You don't have to start
attacking Mikey. You don't have to start
attacking me. Let's talk. Let's
dialogue. If I'm wrong, that's fine. But
if this is true, watch out because God
is going to be the one to lead this, you
know, lead um lead this march.
>> You understand what I'm saying? So
again, it's fine with me. This is just a
conclusion. This was just a you know,
again, when we started off, Ernest, I
was it was a hot potato.
>> You already hurt. You already saw this a
hot potato. People were fuming at the
and you fuming at their heads. Why?
Because you heard something that was
different. And again, brother Mikey,
people are still going to believe
something different. And that's fine.
That is perfectly fine. I still love
them.
>> Amen.
>> I still pray for them.
>> I don't care how strongly um um how
strong in a difference they have towards
what I'm what I'm presenting. That's
fine. But I still will pray for them.
>> You would never hear me. You know, I
don't talk with you degrading anybody
that opposes this view. I don't talk.
>> Okay. It's about we can share our
differences, but let's just move
forward. Now, I can't say that too much
for other people that disagree with me.
They will talk so negative and that's
fine. They did it with Jesus. They did
it with the apostles. They did it with
the prophets. I'm not saying I'm one of
them, but I'm saying if this is true,
you can expect it. You follow what I'm
saying,
>> right?
>> Simple as that.
>> But again, let us remember for those
that believe that the atheism is found
in Daniel 11:40, go back to the second
presentation. Look at time stamp 154.
watch it in its entirety and then you go
from there. That's it. And if I'm wrong
with that, that's fine. But I did I I
believe I exhausted my time to try to
find out what is what.
>> Awesome. I will have at the end of this,
you can put two videos up there. I'm
going to put one and two. I'm also going
to put them in the description and as a
pinned comment. So, just to make it easy
for people to find part one and two.
This is a big study. you know, when you
first told me you wanted to talk about
this and you said, you know, read over
Daniel 11 and uh I think 9 and 11,
it it looked so brief. I was like, man,
how long can this actually be? Here we
are, third part, both of them over three
hours long. And you might even have
more.
But uh
>> but but I'm to be honest with you, when
it comes to really this because in
reality, yes, there is more like to the
>> to the beginning stage of Daniel chapter
11. But because we're living in the last
days and many people want to more tackle
that, I have to start off from the
beginning to get to the end. Okay,
number one. Number two is Mikey is that
I believe one of the reasons why this is
so exhaustive is because God is keeping
us busy in his word.
>> Amen.
>> Okay, he's keep us busy in his word
because a lot of us don't we spend more
time in our phones,
>> right,
>> in our phones than we spend time with
the word of God.
>> That's right.
>> But he's keeping us busy. Okay. So
that's what he's done in times past with
other people and he's doing going to do
with us. So you know to each his own. Go
study for yourselves. Don't take my word
as gospel. You know go study for
yourselves. And I believe that God will
lead you to the to the right. If you
really desire to learn truth, God
through his spirit will lead you to that
truth.
>> Amen.
>> Simply put.
>> Okay. Amen. But remember, I'm the only
one that believes in this. I gave you
some names at the start of our
presentation and there are many more
that hold to that view. So I'm not this
this only one this lone you know person
that no there other people and high
names profile names if you will at least
in terms of our church
>> right so
>> Amen. Well, thank you so much, Ernest,
for coming back on. Look forward to
having you on another time. Maybe it
might be this topic, might be something
else, man. I know you you got a lot of
cool.
>> No, no, you you wanted to handle the
Daniel chapter 9. We got to tackle that
one.
>> Daniel chapter 9.
>> Okay. So, that won't be that won't be
that will be extraordinary. That
>> the 70 that one won't be this long.
>> It won't be 70 weeks long.
[laughter]
>> We're talking about the topic of the 70
weeks.
Yeah, it won't be that long, okay? But I
can promise you that will help a lot of
your listeners to understand. Remember
the issue or like I believe is false
theology about the seven-year
tribulation, the rapture theory.
>> We have to identify it because there
there's a lot of people that are pushing
that narrative out there.
>> And this proves that it's
>> I'm going to show you some I'm going to
show you some documentation. I'm telling
you, it's going to it's going to shock
you, brother. That's a bomb right there
that you just dropped talking about the
seven-year tribulation. So, I challenge
anyone watching this, find me where the
Bible says that there's a seven-year
tribulation. Ask that question all the
time. People say it's in Revelation.
It's not. For one, it's definitely not
in Revelation. So, don't look there. Or
you can you can try, but you can Google
it or whatever. They're going to tell
you it comes from Daniel. And it's man,
Satan loves to twist every prophecy,
every truth, turn it on its head. you.
We got videos on the rapture. And I'll
tell you this, this is a a bomb right
here. You actually want to be left
behind.
That's that's a crazy thing to hear when
you see these movies called Left Behind.
And oh no, you don't want to be left
behind. You actually want to be left
behind. Satan's flipped the whole thing.
And actually, the seven-year tribulation
comes from a prophecy about Christ. And
most churches are saying it's about the
Antichrist. That's how crazy. That's how
that's how deceptive Satan is.
>> They clip a portion of that of those
verses and that is on 26 and 27 Daniel
chapter 9. They detach it from his past
and they springboard it all the way into
the future or they catapult it to the
future.
>> Yeah.
>> They're separating that chapter, you
know, in in that sense. And and and
again um brother Mikey I want to be
compassionate to those people that
believe that there are sincere people in
these Christian denominations or even in
Jewish in the Jewish denomination that
>> that literally believe this and because
they have been mis mistaught
>> I believe the devil is doing this but I
believe that there s they're sincere
people
>> many of them sincere but that's where we
come in brother Mikey
>> amen
>> that's where we come okay and this is
where we need to share with people this
truth and get them Listen, Jesus is
about to come and if we don't get this
out there, the devil's going to cut us
off.
>> We might not have seven years.
>> You know what I'm saying? Literally, we
might not. You get what I'm saying? You
know what I'm saying? And some of us
will be left behind. Literally.
[laughter]
>> Yeah. Exactly.
>> You know what I'm saying? So again, I
don't want to, you know, I don't want to
belittle people that that hold to that
notion, but we have to we have to share
this truth with them. And I believe if
we do it cautiously, tactfully, and
lovingly, I believe that they will a lot
more. Brother Mikey, as you saw how I
presented this case,
>> I did not try, you know, I wasn't trying
to be renegade with anybody in at least
I don't think I am.
>> I wasn't going renegade or anybody.
>> I believe that
>> we can present the truth in love,
brother.
>> Amen.
>> You know what I'm saying? And I'm still
a work in progress. And
>> you know, the Lord has to spack me many
times before. I got a lot of the result
and he has to give me a couple ones.
Listen, whom the Lord loveth, he chasing
the beat times. The Bible says, you know
what I'm saying? So,
>> you did good. You were a good boy,
Ernest.
[laughter]
>> I got a lot of heads in heaven. You know
why, brother?
>> Man, I'm excited about that one.
>> I got a lot of knots on my head. That's
what I mean. If I got a lot of knots on
my head, you know.
>> Yeah. Well, thank you so much, man. And
I'm looking forward to the next one then
to talk about the 70 weeks and pre-trip
rapture and all that stuff. Man, it's
going to be awesome. So, thank you so
much for bringing this. Your name, your
contact, everything's going to be in the
description below. Um, the videos from
before are going to be in the
description at the end of this and in
the pinned comment. Watch that stuff,
man. What there is a lot of information
presented. Don't don't take part of the
puzzle and and you know try to make a
claim about something. You got to see
the whole picture before you can start
making a claim. And that's what I'm
doing. That's what I'm here to do, too,
is is also to see the evidence and see
where everything weighs out.
>> Amen.
>> Awesome. Well, thanks for prayer,
brother.
>> Yeah, sounds good.
>> All right. Do you mind if I pray?
>> Yes, pray it. Our beloved kind,
wonderful, loving father which art in
heaven, hallowed be your sacred and
loving name. I want to say thank you
Lord for giving me the opportunity to
present um this this story, Father.
That's what it really is of end time
events.
Father, I'm not claiming to have
everything all right. I do believe that
I've gained some knowledge by studying.
If I'm wrong, that's that's fine, Lord.
um you can send the right person to me
to to to unveil it to me. Help me to be
humble enough to be open enough to hear
it. But Father, as you will expect me to
do towards others, you expect others to
do with me. That is to the law and to
the testimony. They speak not according
to this word, there is no light. And at
the same time, the Bible says, "Study to
show that self approved unto God, a
workman not needed be ashamed, rightly
dividing the word of truth." All
scriptures given by inspiration of God
is profitable for four things. And Lord,
I pray Lord that we would take into
account those four things. So please
help me also still stay humble.
Um if this is wrong, help me to see
where it's wrong. If it's right, I I
still stay humble. I don't ever want to
pride myself this. And Father, I believe
that when we have a a learning spirit as
a child, we can we can continue to grow
in grace. And that's what I need and
that's what I want. Mikey wants it as
well. Please bless him, his wife, and
the channel. Father, I pray that you
would continue to help them to continue
to get the message out until we meet
again. We still got messages. So, we
need to um to tackle because there is a
world out there that has been misled to
believe a lie.
>> And if you are arm enough with the
truth, help us to utilize this time and
this opportunity to let these people
know that there is truth and his name is
Jesus.
>> Amen.
>> So, thank you Lord for all that you have
done. Please be with the respective
people that have watched here tonight
and those that will be watching in the
future revisiting this channel for
whatever reasons. Please be with them.
And I pray Lord that you would do all
that you can do in order to save each
and every one of them that they will
have the seal of God
>> place.
We love you and we thank you. This we
pray in Jesus most holy and loving and
precious name. Amen.
>> Amen. Thank you so much for that
brother.
>> You take care. Love you my brother. Love
you my brother and we'll see you next
time. And guys, if you were blessed by
this, if you learned something new, if
this was intriguing, give it a thumbs
up. Really helps this video get out into
the algorithm so that more people can
see this. And if you would like to
support this channel, we are 100%
donationbased. We uh this is all we do.
and we go and speak at churches, events,
pathfinders,
uh, whatever your school. We go all the
time in our calendars filling up. And
you can give through candidruth.org,
through Cash App, Vinmo, Zel, PayPal. We
even have Patreon, and we have some cool
t-shirts. If you'd like t-shirts, we get
about $5 per shirt or hoodie or mug or
whatever that's sold there, and that
really helps to keep this channel going.
If you have been giving, we see you. We
thank you. We love you. We cannot do
this without you. And we try to send a
thank you message back to everybody, but
uh Zel and Cash App won't let us. But we
do see you. We love you. We thank you.
We cannot do this without you. And we
will see you next time on Can of Truth.